I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Do you see me?
I'm all up.
Hi?
Question mark?
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon yet?
Hi?
Yes?
Okay.
I'll take that as it is.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Thank you for waiting.
We are doing our meet-in.
Oh my God.
Veiler meet-in.
Exclusive insider information.
What have they got planned?
You'll never know.
You're not going to know.
You won't know until it's ready.
That's right.
Keep your secrets, keep your secrets.
I'm playing Legal Lord of the Rings.
It is a full-screen game, so everything might go black momentarily until we can get in game.
I'm going to pray that the volume settings are right, but you must tell me if they're
not, I will change them in game.
Did I sleep well?
Did I fuck?
Look at it.
Legal Lord of the Rings.
Would we believe it if we didn't?
Load game, new game. Oh my god. Oh, no. Oh, no, you can see that I tested it for a millisecond, okay?
We're just gonna jump right into... right into the...
I just love the image of reflins in a room all getting sick and all you hear is
Stronny in the other room shouting a muffled don't go up. The kettle is bubbly.
That's literally what it was, like I set up the chat and all that.
I'm like the Kales boiling, the Kales boiling, fucking steady on, thank you sleepy fennex.
Literally, you perv thing, but we're back in the shire!
All right, we're gonna get to it. Today's objective. We're gonna play Mission. We're gonna play Mission.
Um...
Now if I'm too big and you need me to be a wee bit smaller in the corner,
let me know because I'm fullscreen and I can't just do it.
Does the volume need up?
You love Lord of the Rings. I love Lord of the Rings. Maybe we should make out or something.
Maybe you should tell me about the lore of Tom Bombadil because I haven't read the books, but I know about them.
Maybe how you should tell me how Saruman's ring technically could be a
technical ring because it fits to any size.
There was a secret ring!
That Mount Doom, the Dark Lord Sauron, forged in secret a master ring to show you all others.
One ring to rule them all.
And one ring to bane them!
But there were some who resisted.
The Sildur! Men and Elves marched it into the fire!
And on the slopes of Mount Doom, they fought for the freedom and the secret volume.
The only thing you know is about Gollum. That's good enough for me.
Now, so the way I play Lego games,
the way I play Lego games is I blast through the missions and then I come back basically.
And we'll come back when we have all characters unlocked.
So I don't particularly go for the unlocks during the campaign mode, if that's okay with you.
So today's objective, we'll go through the missions.
I don't know how long it's gonna take me to get through the missions,
but it's just a small little game about, you know, one of the greatest movies of all time.
What, they've passed out?
It's Brian too quiet, did I forget to turn them off?
Thank you, Reverse, for saving the other replays as they vomited.
But they're doing better now.
Yeah, best way to do pick collectibles.
Yeah, I don't go for collectibles first because it annoys me, like that I can't get them right away.
Um, but I'll try my best.
The game's a bit too loud, hold on, options.
Six, a little bit.
Oh, nope, that didn't work.
Okay, I'll put it down to six.
You tell me what you like about number six, okay?
Because how many times are you gonna clap me for jet?
Oh, sorry, we need to get this.
Oh my god.
Wait, why is the button broken?
Oh my god, the buttons broke on my freaking mouse.
Not my mouse, on my...
Wait, it's actually not working.
I'm pressing Y, Danny, hold it.
Oh, I need to hold it.
Look, I'm pressing Y.
I'm pressing Y.
Look, I was just spanking that thing, okay?
I was spanking that thing, okay?
It's actually beating the crap out of that button.
Okay, it was hold.
When they do the tutorial bit, you have to hold.
Six rules to clap them all.
Real, I'm true.
A moment.
I'm special, okay?
Yes, for those of you who are here,
there is a membership stream, I believe.
That's not a mistake.
Oh, sorry, sorry, Elra, I didn't mean it, mate.
That was a mistake.
Ah, I do have a copache,
because I was calling the way, not meeting.
I was just spanking that thing.
Average.
Ah, enemy.
I got an enemy, enemy.
I'm really going for it today.
This is one of my top 10 games of all time, okay?
Top 10 games of all time.
So these statues here just say,
Save stations, gotta love my safe stations.
I heard Winnell tell, right,
we need the guy with the sword, okay?
So back left is called Mithril,
but we can't do anything with it
until we unlock a certain enemy.
His name is Berserker, actually.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, I completely balls that up.
Sorry, I don't know when he does.
Oh, God, he is really big.
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting nervous, okay?
I'm getting nervous. I'm getting sweaty.
Right, do your owl, right on my forehead.
So he'll get his thing stuck,
and it's the classic, gotta do it three times,
which means it's the best game.
Legosarons, but I think he's actually supposed to be,
like, a huge mongoswap.
Ah, run away.
But yeah, once his thing gets stuck,
he'll basically tallywack him,
and then we make it up to Mentum,
but we need to get close enough
to let the AI actually slam down,
or he will, like, infinitely just go for it, really.
It's a bit of a out.
Yeah, that, that, yeah, that.
Don't do that. That's really rude.
But we need to convince him to slam his wee thing down
so it gets stuck.
Basically. Can you do it now?
Get stuck.
Get stuck, get stuck. Plop, plop, plop.
What are you doing, Stepsauron?
Okay, this one? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no, don't get distracted now.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. There we go.
He's on one health now.
You can see his little health bar in the middle,
but this is best game all time,
like, top 10 game unironically.
I have to say, Assassin's Creed Brotherhood has to be number one.
Would this be number two?
I mean, she...
I think this is a number two for me.
It might be. It might be.
This is top three games,
so I can judge them.
Stepsauron, dear god.
Portal 2?
Speaking of Portal 2,
guess which Vialura Girl hasn't played Portal 2?
And I get to play with her for the first time.
Ah, wee, my face.
Stop it, you hurt my face.
This game was my childhood.
Wow.
This is gonna be an amazing time.
This game was my childhood. It's gonna be amazing.
Oh, it's such a good game, isn't it?
Hello, World of War and Old Warframe.
You nerd.
Oh, he's gonna get me.
So the enemies constantly respawn health for you,
but we should be done.
Okay, there we go.
We got him. Go done, you stinky man.
My eyes are stinky.
Nice.
Skyrim, Diablo, Cyberpunk.
I've still yet to play Cyberpunk.
I'd like to play it for the first time with you.
He lost his tentacle.
That's what you get, you stinky evil man.
Oh, he's Regen.
Oh.
You could probably sell his armor
for some steel and gold and stuff.
Skyrim, Fire, Amblin, Nier.
I've still not played that one.
Sonic Generation.
Darkest Dungeon.
If you can carry me through Darkest Dungeon,
I will be very happy to play it,
but I've never been able to win at it.
I've attempted it twice and I've not won.
Maybe it's one of those things where I need to play offline.
There's more enemies.
But yeah.
I'm not going to try...
Oh, elves have a higher jump than humans
in the game, just so you know.
I am going to try...
And of course, he has the sword that I need to progress,
so I need to come back with him.
I'm gonna try and what?
I don't know, good luck.
I've already forgotten my point,
so you guys just have to finish it for me.
I'm gonna try and play some games for the first time.
Someone recommended me playing Yu-Gi-Oh!
And Poseidon has been playing...
Poseidon's been playing card games,
like Pokemon card, like TCG stuff,
and I'm like, honestly, I wouldn't mind giving Yu-Gi-Oh! a bash,
just for the hell of it.
I want ice summon Pot of Greed!
Pot of Greed! Pot of Greed!
I just wanted to keep going, basically.
Yu-Gi-Oh is so fun.
I mean, I just may, you know.
Now, I would try and go for a full money as well,
but again, I don't really want...
We can do it so easily as soon as we unlock
the times 2 stud multiplier.
It's just not even an issue at this point in time.
I am going to not look up any tutorials
where any items are, any things are.
I have played this game maybe 12 times now.
I'm sure my subconscious will secretly know
what I need to do.
There's stuff up there, yeah, all that jazz.
Lit me in!
There is a funny achievement here
that you're not ready for.
If you drop yourself into the fire below,
you get an achievement and a hidden achievement
is the good thing.
Oh no, I don't think I'm playing this on Xbox.
I'm doing this on Steam because I already had it on Steam.
I don't want to feel...
Oh my god, we're just going to have to replay it again.
Oh, you don't have to tell me twice
that I get to replay it on Xbox for all the achievements.
You don't have to tell me twice.
I'm already doing it.
I tried Yu-Gi-Oh online, got blasted by the broken decks.
I have no idea what the stuff went on at Yu-Gi-Oh.
But we should get an achievement for jumping off the map here.
Achievement, it won't be that easy.
I know I'm covering up the achievement, but yeah.
Literally, it's a funny secret achievement.
I love it, I do it.
I think I can get 100% in this game
achievement-wise if I remember them all.
There's tools to reset achievement.
Destroy it!
No!
What are you doing?
Hesildur!
Is Legolord of the Rings how you suggest women?
This one anyway.
I have been muscle memory from the past.
Take over and get your victory.
The strength of men failed, no.
But the strength of my reflings will persevere.
They have the funniest cutscenes.
I'm so sorry.
There's a really funny one coming out.
Gollum's theme is so weird.
Well, it might not be Gollum's theme, but the Rings theme.
His name wasn't Gollum at the start.
He got corrupted into Gollum by the Rings.
Why does Eldron kill him at the beginning?
I'm pretty sure they were battle friends and all that.
He got hit by arrows while being invisible.
Billboards!
A Hobbit.
Hello!
Stravum?
Actually, Gollum will play right now.
Prologue complete!
We already made it.
Look at all the progress we already made.
Boom!
Hesildur!
Characters available to buy.
Look at all that progress.
Are you not getting serotonin?
Looking at all these things progressing?
I mean, good day!
What kind of games do you play if you're not enjoying this?
None more hate.
You ain't taking my ring.
Give it here.
There is one map in particular
where we're going to have to turn the in-game sound down,
and it's the Swamp's map
because there's a Banshee in it
that screams through the entire level.
Lovely.
Gollum has more wind right now.
It's...
Oh my god!
It's our house!
Yes, yes, yes.
He's all old.
I'm chugging.
I'm chugging the tea.
Bring me one.
Ring.
Drop it.
Did you know?
In order to do the heavy ring effect,
they had a magnet under the floor
so it didn't bounce.
Just thought you should know that.
Just thought it was a cool detail
in order to show how the ring
isn't just a normal ring.
It doesn't bounce when it lands.
I just thought you should know that.
You knew that one.
Yeah.
Look at their chickens!
And our little...
Frodo!
Gandalf?
He's gone, hasn't he?
Stronys is just as you were
lured to the ring trivia.
Oh, stop.
I'll make that right now.
Are we getting...
Okay, I'm already by the end of it.
Did you know
that Aragorn was broken still?
Nobody ever...
I love the cutscenes.
I love the cutscenes in this game!
I'm going to put subtitles on
after this, okay?
That moves the arm.
That's literally me
when I'd be like fucking about it.
If I had the ring,
I'd be losing it over
where I'd be like,
shit.
I lost it.
What do you mean you lost it?
I ain't dropping no eaves!
I ain't been dropping no eaves
so honest.
What's that doing?
Oh my god,
if they ever release a LEGO
like Hobbiton...
Keep it safe.
Um...
LEGO set,
I don't care what the price is,
we're going to do Handcam
building it from start to finish.
I don't care if my butt's in the shot,
I don't care if my feet's in the shot,
I don't care if my wig is in the shot,
we are building that motherfucking bang!
I'll...
I wish...
I wish they would come out with it
because they came out with
a fucking black gate,
like who requested the black gate?
What fanny requested LEGO
come out with a black gate?
Who is not submitting
for Bag End?
for Hobbiton?
Who is not submitting?
Now,
as I said,
I just steamroll the campaign
so I can unlock everything
in order to fly between
locations.
You need to activate the
travel stone.
So we've just activated
the one in Hobbiton.
As you can see,
we can have flight to that
location at any time
or fast travel,
but wait,
we do it on an eagle
if I'm not mistaken.
If you follow the ghost studs,
it will take you to the next mission.
As I said,
I ignore everything
and just go straight
for the campaign.
I'm not actually sure how
long the stream is going to be
or if I'm going to be tempted
to stream a little bit more,
but we're going to go straight
to Farmer Maggot's field.
There we go.
Let's go.
Momy is so active.
Wonderful.
We've got to love Eagle Uber.
There's a Shire game release
and so,
yes,
unfortunately,
the graphics.
So,
Weta Workshop,
I believe,
actually worked with the game studio,
which is good news
because lore-wise,
we love it.
Oh, no,
was it Weta?
Ah,
man,
Pippin!
Ah,
he's getting...
Oh, no,
we're in trouble by Farmer Maggot.
Sam said,
oh,
you're really roping me
into this one.
More than the graphics
is the animal.
Yeah.
This game is cute.
It's so cute.
But we're about to do
the first scary mission.
I think I've broken something.
Huh?
Wait,
he's the guy that says
I'm going on an adventure.
If I take another step,
this will be the furthest
I've ever gone from home
or something like that.
Close enough.
There is a
Legate Hobble set.
Oh, sorry.
Stop!
Is there a Lego Hobbit set
called the Hobbit
on Unexpected Gats?
Shut up.
I don't have my phone right now,
and I don't want to tab out
because it might break the game.
Is he telling the truth
or is he telling porkies
right now?
Please.
Thank you, Stephen,
Boknik
for the super chat as well.
I just realized
I completely forgot to say your name.
Thank you for your patience
if you're still lurking
in the shadows.
I literally read it
and then never said your name.
Sorry!
Unless,
oh no,
it's one of those names
where you can have multiple pronunciations.
Stephen,
Stefano,
I don't know,
close enough.
They all look good enough to me.
Right.
It has a speed.
Sam actually comes in pretty clutch
in the gameplay.
It's real.
It's super expensive.
How big is it?
Or is that a wee thing
or a big thing?
Because I was actually going to do
a Lego building hand cam.
Sorry.
It inspired me.
And I have like this
wee baby Star Wars one.
It's like a wee tiny thing.
It would just be a cute wee thing.
It's real.
It's just the Hobbit hole though.
What?
Like it's not back end
or anything.
Wait, hold on.
I'm grabbing this.
I might as well grab it.
Oh, no, I won't.
I guess I'll grab it
from the other side.
Silly.
Okay, we are going to whack
this tree open.
It's easy money inside.
And right now,
let's go, let's go.
Oh, one of them got caught.
I just heard him go,
ah!
Have you played The Witcher 3?
I have not.
It's one of the games
that I want to play with you
for the first time.
I've kind of planned out
what I'm doing next month.
We are wrapping up Elden Ring.
I've got three days in a row
to wrap up Elden Ring.
Like three, 12-hour back-to-back
in one week.
So I do need stream snipers.
You know, stream,
don't be afraid to stream snip me.
Now, as much as I want to
teleport to another character
and go down,
Sam will be stuck up there
if you do that.
Early thoughts on Geryl.
I watched, like,
15 minutes at episode one
and I just felt
I couldn't finish it.
I'm sorry.
I suck.
Okay, I suck.
Witcher 3 might take
three days to, like, a hundred percent.
Dark Souls 3, obviously.
I have to pick something to go with.
Um, but yeah.
Okay, let's go ahead.
Breaking Bad Watch Along?
I actually have Anime Watch Along.
You're not ready for it.
I'm going to start a series
called Make Me a Weeb,
and we watched 12-shot,
12-episode Animes
together.
So...
I don't know.
It might go well.
We're going to test it with...
I'll start with two
Animes.
I've picked them
and I've already forgotten one.
Wait, one of yous might like it.
Okay, one of yous might like it.
It's called...
Shit, I've forgotten.
It's about two girls.
One of them doesn't have a mum.
They're in high school,
and it's called Sugar Something,
but they kill or something.
I read the synapses
and I was like, fuck yeah,
that's got Mercy written all over it.
I wouldn't watch Animes
that inspire me about the girls.
So I picked the first one
to be, like, this one called
Sugar Something.
You're already a weeb.
Oh, I'm definitely a gamer over a weeb.
So that's why I wanted to start
a fun series called, like,
Oh, Turn Me into a Weeb.
Happy Sugar Life!
Yes, you know it!
You're so smart.
What the heck?
It's, yeah.
I literally typed in, like,
oh, um,
12 episode Animes
that are highly recommended,
and that came up
and I was like, ooh, okay.
So we're going to give it a shot.
See if we like it.
It will be a public watch-along stream.
Like, it's not going to be
a membership stream,
so please don't worry.
Right, see that lock back there?
Fucking slam them into it.
There, you should get that item.
Um, this is one of the most
hidden, annoying treasure boxes.
Unless you know it's there,
you ain't going to figure out
what you're supposed to do.
Um, so we need to get them
to walk away now.
He'll jump to the right
because we're getting too close
to him on this side.
Oh, well, that wasn't quite what we can.
I do want to stay close to-
Look, I'm swinging them here.
I need them, yeah, there we go.
I need them to jump away.
There we go.
And then, you picked up
the most awkward one of this map.
I kid you not.
Have you heard of cyberpunk edge runners?
I have, sadly.
It destroyed me.
He does take HP damage
when you walk on that map.
You know so much about this game.
Very impressive.
I love it!
And I hope maybe I can inspire you
to play it too.
If you think it's up your alley.
But if it's not up your alley,
please don't worry.
I know I don't really play
the games, maybe the majority.
I was actually thinking
about playing PAL World
because I remember it blew up
and I'm like,
you can literally walk away
from his fireballs.
They're not that bad.
But yeah,
if you ever wanted
games that I recommend
and you think we have
the same tapes,
then this game,
pull us out.
If this game
not pull us for you,
that's okay.
That's okay.
And then we did it.
We already did the cutscene.
The music goes hard.
I played this game to death.
I won a cosplay as Rebecca
from Edge.
I don't know,
Runner to Edge
or something,
whatever that anime's called.
I'm teasing.
And I wanted to do
a neck down ASMR stream
dressed up as her.
I thought it would be cute.
So,
we just need to
put this boulder.
We beat up.
They see how the rocks
are kind of going.
The game helps you.
Honestly, don't worry
if you've never played
a LEGO game before.
These games are kind of
like for a more casual
experience.
Nothing try hard.
And especially
if the LEGO game is something
that you're interested in,
i.e.
like Lord of the Rings for me,
you will adore
whatever the game is,
you know?
I think the guy named
David
in Mexican.
What?
What does it mean?
If you cosplay Rebecca,
are we going to
gimbal stomp you?
No!
Don't remind me.
Okay, don't remind me.
Oh, that poor owl
just got walloped
on the side of the head
because of me.
Don't fucking remind me
what happened to her.
Wait.
Hold on.
Everyone, go
annoy the...
Short stacks in the fast
make me go hard!
I mean,
that's what AC is.
That's what AC is.
AC had her comeback stream
today and
she absolutely adored
that she was
gullowing
and happiness
when she came back.
Oh wait, I think it's Mary
that fishes.
I...
You know what?
I knew it was Mary.
I knew it was Mary,
you motherfucker!
Okay, we're going
catch a fish
and we're going
cook it
and we're going to
have something.
Are you excited for
the new dwarf game?
It's supposed to be
like Deep Rock Galactica
about dwarfs
and I'm going to go ham on it.
I'm going to go
green eggs and ham.
No, don't be up the bush.
Throw the crab.
Well, you better
get off the bridge.
Oh, he has to go around now.
Round the outside,
round the outside.
As I said,
Sam comes in clutch
in this game
like all the time
with his abilities.
There is stuff back there
but it is really
to like
miserable on that.
But what about another fish?
To catch a fish,
juicy sweet.
Basically.
Buck them up,
Mr. Go Nature,
go!
Beat them up.
So now what we do
is we go like this
and we're going to shove them
to the next area
because I normally
forget this one
so I'm going to do it now.
Well,
we've had one breakfast.
Yes.
What about second breakfast?
Oh my God,
imagine all the food
I have to feed you guys
on the farm.
I'll be out in that garden.
I'll be making
the best tomatoes ever.
I'm like,
no one's getting prostate cancer
in my farm.
Prostate cancer
scared of us.
It's not the other way around.
Another one now.
Hold on a minute.
Boom!
And then we've done the section
just like that.
You can literally
like go right up to him
at this point
because it'll do the cut scene.
Right.
If I remember correctly,
it's left-right-left.
And if I fuck it up,
it's okay,
we can come back.
But I think it's left-right-left.
You're going to understand
in a second.
So how many four-speeds
do you food than tomatoes
to keep your income prostate
healthy?
Is there one more one?
Yeah,
prostate cancer.
Take a look.
It's so sweet to do.
Legitimately increase
my tomato intake.
It's so good.
Right.
I'm going to do left.
And then
and before it's right,
I wouldn't be surprised
if it was right.
I'm getting nervous.
I'm starting to doubt myself now.
I'm starting to doubt myself
if it's right.
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting shaky.
Okay.
Maybe right side.
Did anyone know
if it's right side?
What happens
if it was right side
and I've missed it?
I knew it was right side!
No!
Did you see it?
Reflint,
did you see it?
I messed up so badly.
It was the
freaking right side
all along.
I messed it up.
I knew it.
It's left, I believe.
Right mods,
time amount for 10 seconds.
It was right.
I'm going to drop that
with the thing.
Did you see it?
Literally the
freaking treasure box.
But we are going to have
to replay it anyway.
So it's not a big deal.
We'll remember.
Does this game
require you to revisit
areas when you've unlocked
a character?
Yes.
So the reason I
steamroll
the mission...
Oh, you actually did
time amount!
The reason why
I personally
enjoy playing the Lego games
by steamrolling
the missions
is because
I then unlock
all the characters
and then I replay
the missions
fully able to get
everything that I need.
Yeah?
Yeah.
So we are
going to be doing
that method.
Mods,
take this ring.
As I said,
I'm not really going to
go for
anything.
I just do
campaign mod.
And then as long as
I have enough money
for Berserker,
who is
an enemy
that has
explosions, basically,
so he can
destroy the myth realm.
The banshee scream
if you fail
dramatically.
Mods, take away
a second breakfast.
Oh!
Can you even say that?
Can you even
say that?
That poor leafling.
What have you done
to him?
He's grating.
He already threw up
his breakfast earlier
because,
you know,
I was a little bit late,
okay?
The meeting went
a wee bit longer.
A wee bit longer than
I had to go.
But that's because
you know me,
Classic County Stop,
yeah.
So we are now
in Breed,
the village of Breed.
And it's so awesome here
and it's so cool.
And this is where
we're going to do the
ting.
So this is where
we unlock the...
So...
We are learning
now the missions
that you can have
in game
when you're not
like when you're not
in a mission,
you can go on little
quests for the people
around the
Middle Earth.
And it is the
cutest,
sweetest,
most adorable thing
ever.
And I love it.
I love it.
So that kind gentleman
is just asked
for a mythril thingy.
So we come over here,
we interact,
we select the
trowel
that we want to make.
And then the
blacksmith
is going to pick up
the
mythril.
He's going to
put it
in the air,
which I've forgotten
the name of,
that blacksmith
called a furnace.
A furnace,
okay.
And then
we're going to jump
on the air windy thing
that goes in a furnace.
I've forgotten
the name of that too.
And it's so cute.
I didn't know that
I got sidequests.
I'm used to Lego games
being more platform.
Yes,
we are going to play
Lego Lord of the Ring.
We're playing it
right now.
We are going to play
Lego
Star Wars,
the original
trilogy.
Not the newest one.
I've actually
not played the
newest Star Wars one
properly.
I like
gave a few missions
and I was like,
apparently they scale
the money
and it was like,
no, the whole
the whole point
the door
literally will not open
unless I
hop out the troll.
You mean the complete saga?
Yeah.
I don't know what I said,
but I do mean the complete
saga.
Thank you for looking past
my words and understanding
what I was trying to say
because
I'm missing out.
Thank you so much.
What does a myth
real troll do?
It means any character
can dig.
So
Frodo doesn't have
the ability to dig.
However,
now he does
with the myth
real troll.
It will always be
on our persons now.
So
it's pretty cool.
To me,
I don't know.
Pretty cool.
So you can like unlock
a fishing rod.
You can unlock fireworks
for explosives.
It's really good
and there's some goofy
fun items too.
It's just called
a forge fan,
honestly.
Jackson Shaw.
Hi, Momay.
Hi, Evelyn.
I miss you.
I'm back already.
Back in the shell.
We're back in the shadow.
Literally us.
Literally.
I'm getting one.
I have
so
getting one.
He disappeared,
but now they know.
Frodo, no.
I see.
Me when you
haven't inked
in 24 hours.
I see.
I should have known
what a troll does
because I want to
dig you down.
Wait,
wait.
Thank you.
They're in the main bathroom.
Giant room.
They're going to sleep.
Love you, Johnny.
Love you, Taylor.
Put that broom
stick on that door.
They were once men.
Why are you taking us
into the wild?
Let's go.
We're going to
Weathertop.
Run.
We need to go to
Weathertop before they
get us.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
So now it's raining
because
there's weather
system in this game
and it's really
cool
and I like it.
So we're going to
make our way to
Weathertop.
It's actually that thing
right there.
I thought it was a bit
more to the right,
but it's not.
I'm going to use
my mithril tool
to fill you up.
So
wait until we make some
more of the item.
I wonder how tight the
clutch is.
We fucking play it.
How are we supposed
to keep up
on no anchoring treatment?
I don't know.
Frodo, you cheated.
You teleported.
So we're going to
unlock this travel stone.
This will help us
be super duper fast.
Super duper fast.
Yes.
We go up there
and stay here.
And we
get to it.
And then we go up
to Weathertop.
This is exactly
the level of
Demon's Soul.
Why does this look so cute?
I don't even know
when this game is produced,
honestly.
Okay.
We all got swords now.
We're getting upgrades.
Upgrades, people.
Upgrades.
Dun dun dun.
Put it out.
Put the fire out.
What do you think?
He said it.
He said the line.
Okay.
So we're going to
make some food
at the mountain top,
which is silly.
We shouldn't
because it's going to
give our way of position.
But look,
we're just mischievous
little hobbits.
We're hungry.
Okay.
We didn't have
11 Zs for once.
second breakfast for two.
Damn right,
we're hungry.
Of course we're hungry.
Shocking behavior.
So now we've got
a fish in the pan.
Now we're going to
put tomato in the pan
because this is going
to groove the tomato.
We got
Yeah.
Frodo's asleep right now.
He doesn't know
what shenanigans we're
getting up to.
We're going to beat this up
and we're going to get
a tomato,
a tomato.
We're going to put it
in the pan
and then we just need
to get an egg
and then
after the egg.
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
We need to go up here.
So we need to
just rebuild the track
really quickly
and we can move the rock
out of the way
and then we put
the egg in the pan
and then we just need
to get the egg section.
Oh, and it'll be
no 11 C's,
no second lunch,
honestly.
I'm going to beat this up
because there's a bit of
wood in here.
I want to climb back up
after I've claimed
back down,
but there is a wee egg
in this tree.
I'm beating up.
I actually thought
I fed
my magpie
three times yesterday
and it's
Dad's magpie
and the daughter
and I'm like that just
straight up call them
Ronnie and
Strontium
like me and my dad
as magpies
because
I'm kind of tempted to
where the heck is his last one?
Oh, it's by the tree base.
I see it.
Do it.
Yeah.
They called on me
three times yesterday.
I was
so surprised.
So
the baby,
like the girl,
she was so scared
and she never like approached.
Now
now she's
outside my door
on
which is literally
the feed me call
as if I was a parent bird to her
which is not
in the
thing, but she
she called on me
while the dad wasn't there
and I was like, right.
Okay.
Put it out.
Nice.
Ash on my tomatoes.
I love the week.
Love something bad happens to them.
Magpies live 30 years.
Go, go, go.
Even the bird is calling your mommy.
Literally,
the thing's like
and I'm like,
I'll feed you,
but I'm not actually more hidden.
You can that, right?
Oh,
right.
Okay.
So if you're going to fall off the map,
if you're fast enough,
you can swap to another character
to not take the penalty for falling off,
which is losing some of your money.
I was so sorry, Sam.
I didn't mean it.
You're,
you just had such a reach.
Okay.
You just had such a reach.
Do you have problems with the cats
and the magpies fighting?
No.
Gimli likes watching them.
So
one time,
Gimli may or may not almost
escaped and
tried to hunt
strongy the magpie,
but obviously I stopped her in time
and I opened up my arms
to make the magpie fly away
because I never do that kind of thing
around them,
and I would stress them out or whatever.
So when I did it,
the magpie knew something was wrong,
but whenever I throw cashews out,
Gimli goes to the window to watch them
or I leave the door open
because they walk right up to the door.
They're not messing around.
I was very stressful.
I can laugh on it now,
but I kid you not,
if Gimli did something,
I would be distraught
because I love my magpies.
I really do.
But they're really good cat TV
entertainment when you feed them.
I buy small bird feed mix as well
for the pigeons
because the pigeons beaks.
So magpies have incredibly strong beaks,
but pigeons beaks can't handle it.
Seagulls beaks can't handle it.
So I do buy small mix as well
for the wee birds.
They're quite cute.
Oh, rather cute.
Gimli watching her prey.
She is a hunter.
Sorry, but she's so dangerous.
It's insane to watch her body language
change when she spots a bird as well.
A completely different body language.
Her ears get pinned back.
She's so excited.
She starts chirping.
Oh, this.
It's quite scary.
Is Gimli one of the short cats?
No.
Vigo is the one who's afflicted with half munchkin.
So he doesn't have very good joints, thankfully.
He is mixed with a full breed of tabby.
So he's not as unhealthy,
but I'm aware that he doesn't have his good jump.
One time my half angle was outside
and found wild mice.
She didn't know what to do,
so she just meowed loudly
and watched them run around.
Stop fucking.
Oh, sorry.
Just walked off the map.
Gimli is the one
that has the strongest hunter's instinct.
Vigo caught a rat out of nowhere.
He almost brought it inside the house.
I was like,
don't, don't.
I managed to stop him
before he came through the cat flap,
but I was like,
do not bring a rat into this host.
Because, yeah,
I was so surprised he caught it,
but I think he's secretly a good hunter as well.
Just not birds,
but I think he's good at pest control like that.
But it was a gift.
Oh, no.
I went outside and praised him for it
and gave him treats,
but they don't bring it inside the host.
That didn't want any thingy,
but cats are very good for pest control like that.
I mean, I could like,
oh, maybe I should do that in my education stream.
I should like,
say can we go to Sam's
so I can actually see what I'm doing.
This is the most annoying quest ever.
It is so annoying.
So these guys like follow you around
and it's just silliness.
They like kind of half attack, half don't.
I don't know if you can tell on screen.
They're currently attacking Frodo.
So when I have to swap back to Frodo,
he's going to get attacked and I just,
this is probably one of the most like,
not frustrating.
It's not that bad if you know what to do,
but the first time you play the sequence,
it's like, bro, leave me alone.
Perhaps he wants to feed you food, honestly.
But no,
maybe the education of why cats
have always been so loved in society
is because of pest control.
They help with the population.
They help with ensuring that,
sorry, I just need to check
where the last one is, maybe this one.
And then Frodo deals with the other two.
You thought they were drunk, literally.
Like they hover around,
but if you get touched by them,
you basically get locked into this really annoying
animation that you need to fight out of
and it's like, eh.
Just let me make my progress.
Just let me make my progress
and my favorite video game.
Life is like a video game.
But yeah, once you're Frodo,
you build two fires
and you just go straight back to Sam
and it's all easy peasy.
The game will indicate
if you no longer have to do any,
oh, I just, you didn't see that.
I may or may not have just
scolded myself in the fire by accident.
Has Johnny played straight?
I have.
I did it in one stream,
one full VOD,
so if you ever wanted to watch that, you can.
I think it took me like,
five hours to do.
But if you ever wanted to catch up on a VOD,
I always just recommend
maybe like doing it on 1.5 speed.
Two, I start to sound a bit squeaky
if you two times me.
One time my orange cat, Salron,
the moment she sees anything
she considers it prey,
her ears pin back,
oh, her ears pin back,
and once I go in full evil mode.
Yeah, they're pupils' dialy, so cute.
Stray's so good, I love it.
She sang every time too.
Yeah, we gave music to the music guy,
like the sheet,
and I just started randomly making up songs,
which was quite fun.
What do I need to do?
I think, if I'm not mistaken,
we need to burn the wraiths manually.
As I said, there's a few things
in this game that's like,
but it's honestly, in the grand scheme of things,
it's not that bad.
So I told Sam to make this fire,
and then, oh, you didn't see that.
You didn't see that? That was embarrassing.
But we're basically going around the map
and trying to find a stone
so we can get a new torch,
and then we're going to light the torch on fire,
and then we're going to whack it on them.
As I said, the campaign is just a really well-rounded game.
I may be biased because I really enjoy
the Lord of the Rings,
but for me, it's very...
My game just froze!
No! Not me praising how well-rounded the game is,
and it froze! You didn't see that.
It is a good game.
I promise it's a good game.
You didn't see that.
I'm so... I'm sorry.
Okay, it's a good game.
Right, where the heck is this last piece of rock
that I need to throw?
Oh, wait, is it in Sam's pocket?
Yeah, the game does that
where they'll hide an item in the pocket of someone,
and you're like, rub, please.
Just like that.
You jinxed it. I literally did.
I actually did.
It is a good game.
Okay, by panic there.
The game does have good auto-save features.
Morgal blend.
I almost underprinted straight on my first playthrough.
Oh, no.
I didn't do exploring like that in the game.
Weathertop completo!
We've already done three missions.
A regorne son of our...
I love the visual gags and all that.
Please wait until we get to the funeral.
I crack up.
I don't know if...
Because I'm expecting to laugh at it,
I probably won't laugh,
but I crack up at the funeral,
but it's absolutely outrageous.
Absolutely outrageous.
Boom.
I've already done three.
I tried Little Kitty Big City.
It was kind of like Goose Game and Street,
but it kept making me think
about how much I want to be back in a city from Street.
Oh, no.
Frodo got stabbed.
But a pretty lady's going to save him.
I win.
Ooh, you're so pretty.
You're so ethereal without even trying.
He really said,
oh, pretty lady.
Well, look at that hair twirl.
Look at those lines to indicate a female Lego.
Ooh.
He's fading.
Replings hold on.
She's at home.
I've been looking for you for two days.
Where are you taking him?
We must get him to my room.
Frodo.
I offered only a gear.
Torquoise me, baby.
Wow.
I do not fear them.
I used them.
Honestly.
Ne.
It's okay.
There, there, Frodo.
You'll feel better soon enough.
We're done.
See?
Already into the next mission.
He's fading.
Like my hairline.
Oh, no.
What leafing sore.
why does the lego girl have a 60 block?
oh obviously
oh what do you mean you don't want to shag a piece of lego?
obviously the scene was a bit more impactful in the actual movie but lord of the rings they
did it justice i think they did it justice
wow
so we are now heading to the lovely elden
it's not really a village it's like a city is it a citadel would it be described as a citadel
i don't know but we head in there we shmoving along on the horse
and we're here
where am i you are in the house of error
candle yes the surfboard of my crate it looks like what happened candle
i was delayed
just a wee bit delayed totally wasn't on a
uh
i'm using i'm opening my bottle of water to hydrate
hi who's silver
i'm sure
there's that man fuck your mom
oh
you must heed his words or ogre for you
he's like a puppy dog okay
instructions to come together
hi we in revendell the citadel i think it's a city
so we are now in amongst the elves oh my god the elves lovers we're gonna give the elves a big
old oh hold on do you want to hear the voiceline i'm gonna see if she's here oh no she's not
uh i spoke about having a voiceline i thought it was because i'm an elf over here
but i might maybe it's the hobbit it might be the hobbit right i'm not going that way that's the
one way you're among the elves done done done done done done right we're gonna unlock the teleport
map stone sorry not the teleport stone but as you see when you unlock the map it'll tell you
all the collectibles on the HUD i went to skippity-doodle skippity-day that because we're
gonna send it hello elves all you're also nice and kind we now are going to start our quest
because we aren't technically on the quest for the ring yet fully
um the the fellowship of the ring if you will
begin
so
one does not simply a gift to the foes of mordor
why not use this ring you cannot wield it none of us can one ring answers to sauron alone
and watch would arrange you know this matter this is no mere range
oh my god lego lego last literally just went in actually
and actually he's not just a ranger
lego lego i literally i started saying lego last because i was like wait i'm playing lego but
his name is lego last yet no literally i started
this is indeed the will of the council
mr furtows not going anywhere without me
we're coming to
nine companions you shall be the fellowship of the ring
oh they get to meet each other
my throat
i'll protect them
oh my god
it glows blue when orcs are closed and it's times like that my lad when you have to be extra careful
lego last way
the ring bearer is setting out on the quest mount
the fellowship awaits the ring bearer
huh
oh at least he washed his hand
at least you
bye bye i love you arwin oh my god you guys should get married and have babies or something
i don't know quest of men
i thought this thing was the coolest when i was young
we have formed the fellowship
look at me i'm proto baggins and i have loads of equipment now
the physical comedy of the lego games are superior literally imagine trying to sum up
all the dialogue and things that happen in a film within a two-minute cut scene
like you're trying to mass compress like the tiniest thing into uh literally two
minutes uh no massive ass things until like a tiny funny ha ha thing um and you have to
put your own spin of humor on it as well and i'm like bro i do not envy the writers but yes
we've unlocked lego last so elves can double jump um and they also have bow and arrow access so
we do have slightly more mechanics unlocked gimley can actually my cat is going to be
going nuts thinking i'm talking about her gimley can destroy heavy plates on the ground now so
we're already starting to unlock the core mechanics when we go back and play missions
we are now going to do the pass of car i can never say it right but you're not ready for this
but all i'm going to say to you is the ladi da okay i'm saying ladi da and then when we listen
to the background of this mission please tell me you do not hear him literally go ladi da okay
your cat can break plates real he's slipping did you know in the film production everyone was
getting smacked in the eyes with like this horrible material and everyone's eyes were read in these
scenes because they were getting bra it shoved in their face with all the fake snow
i don't know man kind of like you cared a little bit there handing over sassy
vodka right so we need to pick up gimley in order to get him through the heavier snow it is the
cutest mechanic ever we can also toss him just thought you should know you know very lower friendly
very lower accurate more cool trivia yes if you look at the behind the scenes when they were doing
the snow scenes everyone hated it because they were getting like obliterated in their eyeballs
it was terrible white substance and red eyes you say how do you i actually already need to pee
and i feel so bad because i've just gone started oh wait no sorry uh hobbits cannot lift gimley it
has to be uh like a like a human well there's my monies didn't mean it but hey ho and it should
all lock for the most part ta-da go it's bad for you hold it in i might like to go pee i need oh
sorry hold on give me up give me up give me up i need to pee okay you guys jump up from there
i think so right okay gimley do as a favor mate do as a favor jump up no and then do
ah and then yeah okay there we go uh the game can be a bit uh pernicate like that which is a bit
annoying but it is what it is it's not like a big hole breaker sure right here no that's icy in the
snowberries thing you're not inhaling my pants all right we'll finish this mission i will very
quickly go and pee it will literally be a millisecond because i've already got all my drinks and stuff
and when i get hungry later um i can definitely it's not this one but the next one has like a
hidden thing under it i don't think we can okay and then we build strongy need no sport star right
thank you too whoa hold wait that was an inside thought that came out i'm sorry please forgive i
wasn't thinking yeah i got like i think i got four hours of sleep or something oh you never saw that
it was a it was a mistake right hold on let's try that again yeah um but right where is legolas
you are next why so little sleep fill up doing stuff like i had to prepare the notes for the
meeting and um i was up working and i've recorded the audio i literally just need to put the sfx so
after the stream um gives me like 30 minutes and i will upload the audio on patreon thank you everyone
for your unwavering patience for me but um yes the audio has been recorded it's been cut up i
literally just need to put down the sfx where i rip your pants off violently um and then you guys can
enjoy the hilarity that was creating that audio it was absolutely outrageous it was outrageous but
i figured that you guys are more than patient and you understand that if an audio is literally
12 hours late that it's not like um schemas and or anything and it's just what happened
and when we try to get a seven hour sleep challenge is it impossible i don't know we're
gonna find out this is a job for legolas now the game normally does guide you oh wait hold on nope
take your bow and arrow out and then do this and then we can just swing across okay i guess just
do one uh so gimley can't get up here until you do like character select like a free play that's
what it's called when you do free play in this game um thank you for everything you do amina oh
you're more than welcome yes uh once i upload that then that is you know the month of july
um completely dealt with i don't know if i've hit all those i don't know if you can do it in the
first round i'm falling off the map sorry if you saw that i was falling off the map and i panicked
um and then we get to uh there's been good progress with scripts behind the scenes um
um who or what is this a gimley one or is this a photo one there's nothing uh a sam one no it must
be gimley when you unlock a new mechanic the game does get you to do it like a billion times over
and it's like red it is it's gonna matter i love this game more than the movie i mean this game's
a lot easier to like tune out to whereas i would argue the lord of the rings me
that terrified me i did not expect to hear anyone talk and i was like uh excuse me what the actual
fuck are you doing in my house um yes um i'm gonna work on ac's youtube roleplay next because
i'm very excited for that to come out um and she was like so happy i don't know if you guys
managed to watch her comeback stream type thing she was so happy to be back and i'm so happy
i'm so happy ow ow i just got fucking walloped by a rock but i'm so happy that she's happy type
thing um like it's the simple things in life just the simple things uh right i think we get
ah why am i so bad at timing this i'm getting hurt everywhere right where is i need a human to
you'll need to toss me i'm working on it i'm working on it i'm working on it you stop you you stop
jumping up and down there young man go um she was happy to see the snowberries again um it was just
one month uh one week yeah but she loved this right what's this it is a dig so we actually
need sam to come over so we're gonna go grab sam we're gonna manually jump him over and we're
gonna go back on you and we'll grab you then we're gonna bring you over uh the writers were quoted
and i do have like this month like so much behind the scenes progress that's going to be made i had
like a really big update i've got a second manager uh in the works um as well but i did warn the girls
if and when they come into play uh the that manager is not as nice as me uh and not as lenient
when it comes to things so you know just warning you know um they get shit done
but i have warned them that if and when but they are there's two managers that are gonna come in
a later date and one of them's super nice and the other one's a bit of a hard ass and
but i am needing needing some results eggs eggs the need some results
then me the new manager has a big sick sam what are you doing go back down sam and now
gimley's coming out so i can't come see this one doorway system sam if you stayed down we didn't
we wouldn't have had to do this bad cop good cop i mean it's not on purpose but i know this manager
will get the results type thing and whereas like you know i'm just like i'll let you do what you
want for the most part but you know yeah oh wait hold on you didn't see that that was about wait
why did that not get on the board right okay there you go
am i too late okay now go let's go
and oh we did it i didn't realize we could actually do this one and then if you come to the end you
actually get the recipe as well there's it's just a little bit hidden off map there are a few instances
of that happening the bad cop is the one that makes people work better plausible and
very plausible as i said they aren't coming in until much later
blah blah blah and we're going to melt this and then everyone can jump across and then we'll
get legolas to shoot those and then we're done already there's another level down like play
this game is just so fantastic you can tune out you can try hard as much as you like for any of
that sometimes it does glitch out just a little bit and but that comes later the dwarf toss is
such a great game but there you go look now everyone can jump across the platforms we're
going to go on legolas and then shoot this and then throw gimley and then that's
you know you can shoot two things at once i uh dictate right for 2012 a very polished game
wait Assassin's Creed came out before this game i'm learning okay now just run ahead literally
just run ahead to end it as you can see the camera's like a thunderbolt not this time though
hydration check replays make sure you're hydrated
well thunder battle is in the whole bit i remember watching the thunder bell in the whole
bit i was like what the fuck what do you just say fruto you got me hard decisions
we will go through the minds the minds of moria
ac1 and 2 came out before this game i'm not sure about
when
oh yeah there's also elfin orc uh no elfin um dwarf uh racism because there always is
whenever there's like a fantasy game there's always some sort of like weird like
but it's like i don't know
i am gonna purposely purposefully break all the balls if i can find the rocks because i can
actually do that right now oh god i can't remember where everything is forgive me i suck
all right where's the fire it should be here okay sam i'm gonna need you first darlin out you come
um speak reefling and enter oh that is so good sweet
we're gonna build a fire then borrow me i need you to drop all the wood that you picked up
because it's on your person and then we need to do an elf over there not to be confused with
elfin ships and where is the last rock there should be a rock on the shore but i guess not
okay we got the last fire the oh wait hold on there's like a rock you are a rock that's why
okay we're just gonna very quickly get this uh pick up so we don't have to like it's not really
backtracking that much do not stir the water uh right okay i'll stir the soup then
not the horror that is elf on the shelf bro i've seen some bizarre videos about elf on
the shelf where like children are like screaming in terror because they were told like the magic
is lost if they touch the elf i could have sworn it was like a little sister grabbed it
and like the the other children were screaming bloody murder like bloody murder me and i'm like
oh my god how rather terrifying yep
we're getting there let me just very carefully walk the plank and push this down and then we
gotta do it on one more side and then we're done see on that side we need gimley to go over here
oh i missed okay he's supposed to be on the floor he's supposed to be on the floor forever
was there a study that said elf on the shelf can cause trauma i mean i honestly wouldn't doubt it
i'll stir your war we'll be fine i don't want refillings i won't do elf on the shelf okay i trust
i won't i won't upset you like that we won't do it i wouldn't want to upset you you're darling
feeling you have you screaming murder because you think like the magic is gone or lost or whatever
okay we do that and then we break it and then we build the door and then we do the boss fight
and we're done another one oh yeah i'm a one step closer to full achievements in this game even though
i should probably be doing this on xbox right now but you know what it's fine we'll come back to it
i'm needing to kind of get a bit closer to the goals i was wanting to do
strony on the bonnie on your bonnet more like hi hi i'm strong
oh no worries the magic is long gone from my life oh oh that's so sad
i'm sure it's there just hidden in a pathway in your brain you've not used for a while
your little chicken thigh brain huh your little chicken breast you and you need to go to the bathroom
break yes i need a pee i'm aware i'm currently like going side by side in my chair right now
trying to hold in my my piss right how do i do this i can't remember is that a gimp
and then maybe a leg last burst that needs to do something or i think it just needs to come down
like any gimme
uh yeah okay that looks right oh wait it's multiple okay and then it's a leg last shot
i think gimley then leg less and gimley then leg less because you need to shoot him in the eyeball
the end do i not look at frodo in the back getting violently like whipped about that's such a shame
he's trying his best to survive okay he's trying so he's getting absolutely walloped about back there
hmm i keep falling asleep on my desk i need to go for a nap yep i've recommended that
i almost let it be on when you wake up because this is an injured dream kind of i don't know
i can't remember how long the campaign section takes with the speedrun up
um i don't think it's too bad as far as i'm aware
let's go and then it's the sniping point yeah there we go wow i lose the it's my dad boogie woogie
you'll have to toss me go gimley go funk
go lego let's go no don't eat frodo that's bad naughty that's naughty don't do that
sponk don't do that now your other eyeball oh no it's randomly flailing around prepare for
random play oh ah is it gonna put other armor cross it's flailing evasive maneuver serpentine
serpentine okay there we go we toss them we pop his other eyeball and we're good to go
don't swallow the lego pieces yeah why were you guys getting emmy to eat lego on her stream
by the way i saw someone clip something of that matter why are you trying to get emmy to eat lego
did i miss a few steps what was happening in that stream huh what was happening
i'm doing a quick search i says 34 hours of doing a hundred percent
full shite full shite it does not take 34 hours to 100 percent this game
i'm submitting myself for a speedrun right now i don't think i won't no it's okay there there give
the path of kindness okay i'm gonna go for a big old piss um i'll only be a moment because
i literally um the toilet's like right there and no before you over unlocking people who are we
unlocking i can't tell from the shadows unfortunately oh a big stretch big stretch oh and we're 100
thousand studs oh my god we're so rich we're so rich we're doing it we're making all the money
i'm making the best money's ever what we're making i can't recognize that it's probably the monster
and we got the blacksmith we got a cluster boat that'll help with many missions so we will try and
make that back into the trenches we got no stop throwing up don't start don't start to prepare
to throw up i'm literally peeing for like not even a minute the toilet is right there it's right
there how do i'll throw you into the mission actually you don't want to keep forgetting to do
putting subtitles on subtitles on good right we're gonna go next i'm gonna leave you in the cutscene
okay look you look it's entertainment jingle jingle jingle i'm putting key i'm dangling keys
in front of the screen jingle jingle jingle you just pay attention to the mission okay jingle
jingle jingle jingle jingle the keys jingle the key jingle jingle jingle okay okay
soon master out you will enjoy the people's hospitality of the dwarves roaring fires red
meat off the boat into the winds
they now have about one choice
in this face the long dark
this my friend is the home of my cousin bolly and they call it a mine a mine
oh
we must move on we cannot linger
uh
jingle jingle jingle does the game keep you entertained are you okay are you okay i'm
literally putting my clothes back on because i have to take them off for to go to the toilet
are you okay are you okay darlin it's okay i'm here stop throwing up no what do you
just throw up just nausea it's okay it's okay can i get one of the refunds to clean up after
the ones that throw up that would be okay i'm just trying to i'm just trying to uh play the game a
bit okay thank you don't stay down i put in calcour i'm glad you didn't throw up too much
i'm sure you guys are okay i'm copy i'm copy i'm i'm sure you guys are okay i'll actually
pee so fast i was like what do we need the cog i can't actually remember where it is
uh i got that so i think i'm on the right tracks
ready i still need the cog though
sam legolas
need a key have a cog are you a key pick you up okay there we go key
open i've just got a bucket thank you i can't believe the cutscene didn't help me stall far enough
how dare it okay let's go help little fool of a toke um peppin oh is it peppin no i'm fool of a toke
i just remember that you fool of a toke there he is okay i got it
oh we're up chicreek what's next a bionicle game do they have bionicle games
hi johnny hi thanks for joining us we're playing lego loaded the rings but you're getting the
speedrun version because we're doing all the missions first as fast as we can and then we're
going to unlock all the characters that we need to go back and do the missions someone claimed
that it takes 38 hours 100 percent this game it absolutely does not i can assure you it does not
maybe maybe for uh can you jump up on that thank you uh maybe for a complete noob uh yeah but for
someone that's just so good at the game like me obviously not um minecraft lord of the rings
is that a thing no no i i read that wrong wait we're not at that bit i think we're at the bit
where we just need to be up the enemy to come through and then we're going to unlock a bigger
enemy that we need to deal with and lego last is very good for like sniping past all the enemies
and just making sure you're only hurting them until the next sequence comes they're coming
no do not randomly start attacking Frodo that's one thing about this game i wish didn't happen
you will auto attack friendlies and it's like no there's literally three enemies around of course
i'm not actually wanting to hurt uh Gandalf strongy scuttles our way through the mines honestly
you're in the mineshaft looking for diamonds i'm in the mines looking for mine
i don't care it's funny it's a funny meme or edit or song i don't know what it is
and they have a cave troll they have a cave troll does the ai take friendly damage yes i can
straight up like perish my allies so we need to go up here we need to break this we need to stand
on it and then the cave troll will lock onto us and we need to either avoid the hit but if we don't
it's not a big deal but climb on the chain aim at its face and then fobs your uncle and it's your
fanny and life's good we can see that there's something actually hidden there can you see that
white outline boom i just spotted it last second but we've walloped him over there so we're going
to come back over here now and we're going to do the exact same thing as we did before we're going
to stand on this the cave troll will lock onto us ai wise and then we avoid it jump on the rope
and hit them in the face just like that like easy peasy lamasque zove and we are going to go back up
because i think we need to do it a third time the classic uh need to do it three times and we're
good to go and wait why is it giving me that question mark why is gimley going up gimley can't walk
with him people sus i don't remember this i don't think he's supposed to go up there am i
messing this up oh my god how embarrassing imagine trying to like be like oh my god i played this
game so much i love this game so much and then i'm doing it wrong how embarrassing how could i forget
there was one in the middle how could i be so foolish in my ambitions and not lay them to rest
let's see ai's locked on jump oh well i was gonna wallop himself in the face oh
okay i forgot this bit i forgot this bit okay the blinks allegations we're hitting again poor
frodo can he catch a break when he gets stabbed and then healed from like a morgo blade now he's
getting shanked by a cave troll when he's like two feet off the ground like come on gi frodo a break
oh my gosh i'm guessing your luck stat goes down
okay now this is annoying you need legolas to be on standby to shoot the damn thing or is it
ah i'm an idiot yep or else you have to go through that sequence all over again and his
fucking get out of my way you bam okay now this is when i need the little guys to jump on
the enemy i'm not mistaken i can get any of them to jump on his back or am i making this up
i'm gonna be honest i've forgotten this one oh no hold on there's a little little ring
so again you need to get in position to help legolas shoot him in the mouth basically so i'm
gonna put him in the middle and face him like this on purpose and i'm gonna get legolas i'm
gonna bring him over and pray that that random enemy doesn't i'm gonna pray that a random enemy
doesn't do that very exact thing um yeah um so i again just do the exact same thing if you
cannot enable yourself to do this as fast as possible life is easy people and it's a loser
i can see that legolas has an enemy right on him so that's perfect timing just to really upset me
the game knows how to upset me very well it does of course get out of my face honestly boom and then
we're done never just sitting here on the floor proof photo i was just saying the red brick that
gives you invincibility is very satisfying because like yeah what you're gonna do you can't hurt me
you can't hurt me yeah he has courage
it's blinding oh i'm putting no likes on
to the bridge
oh i forgot about this little baby mission
i'm gonna say controversial not all goblins can crawl upside down on the ceiling i feel like
some of them would fall down i said what i said okay i don't i don't trust them all right i'm gonna
be legolas so every time we kill how many is identified a Gandalf will move us forward to
the next objection objective objection is what they say in court when they don't agree with something
i don't know i don't know i don't know but um yeah i've actually forgotten how many missions
are in this game but i want to say we're doing okay we're on we're on time for the world record
we absolutely or not i'm sure there's some massive exploit that lets you finish the game in two hours
i used to watch tons of speed runs on games that i enjoyed just to be like wait so how fast
these people finish it um and i was always like mortified by the result i remember typing in like
the speed run record for pokemon ruby because like that game the fastest i've ever done it is
like in one sit in like 12 hours and the speed run is like one hour 58 minutes and i'm like
okay talk about me like not being um fucking fast as fuck boy
objective based on e goblina oh my god goblin girl for gen four confirmed
that's right the gen four jokes are starting already how dare you
you 100% in eight hour yeah that's no happening with me no chance absolutely no chance
let's go run run run run as fast as you can you can't catch me on the gingerbread man
um i'm not maybe one day okay so there's a little goofy door mechanic area
which i think is cute but i like it so pippin's little ability at where the heck is he on the
deal pippin pippin he has water he has a little bucket and he can move water and he can hydrate
plants or he can put out fires just like that um and the legolas i'm gonna need you to grab
gimli so you can throw him at that thing unless he doesn't need to be thrown i don't know
oh it worked i'm not complaining um and then i believe it's gandalf's time to shine
very shortly make some one of these there's like a there is that's literally the very
iron we need it i love it here ginger yes bread only when you respond moment okay that's
i'm interested to see how peggle goes this week as well i just remember playing it
and where is gandalf gandalf can you do me a favor can you do this bit please thank you well the
magic is that was very weird to control i'm gonna be honest that was bizarre to control that was not
like put it here kind of physics that was different and throwing gimli with legolas is foul honestly
the please think of the lore implications you'll have to toss me imagine having your only special
in the world of magic with masters warriors is that you're holding a bucket at all times hey look
even the smallest positive impact is still positivity overall okay um
it still has good impact on i think i get an item here yeah i do we technically have collected
our first item but yeah we're about to do this little pathway but fly you literally the speedrun
record for portal window glitches is 14 minutes oh get a rest 14 minutes the development team must
be although actually i've watched the fallout new vegas development team watch someone's speedrun
and they were like amazed at what was going on because obviously they kind of understood a bit
what was going on behind the scenes with everything and um it was rather entertaining to watch
never caught a stream before this what you you like lego lord of the rings turning you on
yeah yeah you like all the facts i'm telling about the game yeah that's what you like what game was
this uh fallout new vegas the development team i don't know if you type it in if you type like
fallout new vegas dev team watches speedrun they were like talking about how they only had like
16 months to put this game together and like the budget was just like you know and then it ended
up being the most popular fallout game just because of everything they did now when you do the sequence
in the game you will be very tempted to swap off a character and think sam will climb up on his own
he won't don't fall for it don't fall for the bait okay oh lego this is the helmet on that i picked up
just like that shawnee the hall is crushed colfish there is i think i might be the only colfish
retriever at this point in time i don't know i'll need to look it up i've actually not looked to see
if there's like another check that's a colfish because it would be kind of cool if we both like
had a hidden thing going all right but i think i might be doing one i'm not sure
okay this part i'm getting nervous about because this is the most glitchiest part of the game
about to come out if we get past it glitchless i'll be happy um but the longer you play lego lord
of the rings the more instances are generated i know that sounds bizarre but the longer you
play it the more likely you're going to run into a problem or a glitch or whatever
oh i got shivers and i'm literally looking at a cube okay it means a lot to me it means a lot
lego balrog honestly they did amazing with the design
um so what made you go i'm gonna make pregnant ASMR i like shit posting okay and then i wanted
to be pregnant with the reeflings and then when i made it and i put the heartbeat in it and then
i put the muffled voice on it and then i put my stomach sounds in the game in the game in the
video and then i uploaded it with subtitles and then everyone clicked on it thinking i was going
to meme and it'd be a massive shit post but i actually put all my love and time into it okay
this is the most glitchiest part of the game i am praying we don't glitch out praying we don't
glitch out it's the most i have never had more issues with any scene in the game than this one
and the worst part is it's right at the end of the level there's like one thing we have to do
Frodo gang and then it's the really sad part of the movie where um we gandalf in it because they
think he's popped his wee bugs um but i'm praying it looks good it looks like we're not running into
the glitch it's the infinite dive glitch even when you dive um balrog or the sword do not get
any closer to you but we look we're looking good we're looking good we're looking good we're looking
good i think we're doing mighty fine so we just need to avoid as we attack i don't think this is
actually doing any damage to them we've just got one more of these to do copy them i literally is a
bottomless hole i get genuinely we only have to do it one more time come on game i believe in you
don't glitch out now or i'm gonna great the sword is getting closer okay good good and
then we're gonna dive for balrog please get closer i think we're okay i think we've okay
worst part of the game is officially over we're not gonna glitch out at this stage because we don't
have to do the dive sequence again we're just spamming away
surely copy i'm gonna be fine
whoa whoa whoa whoa you reverse your special kind of feature bird oh my i love that thank you my
mom calls me special too so did my teachers at one point as well
look i like what i like i like what i like is likely to go wow is it that likely to go to
i've played this game multiple times i've had issues with this scene the most this is the worst
scene okay but this this section does it so i've done it the balrog sequence is over the
likelihood of us experiencing major glitches or anything of that nature very very small now
incredibly small don't want to jinx it no come on now come on now don't want to jinx it but uh yeah
we're gonna we're gonna be alright we're gonna be alright and okay we need to get the reel up so we
can get the weans up uh what's that oh i think it's the treasure chest on the wall oh it is there's
just chilling right sure we'll we'll grab it while we're at it why not all right there we go so now
the wee ones can come up and then gimley just needs to smash the door open thank you reverie
famous last words the balrog fight was used as gal doll's intro into the weird lego crossover game
so i i'm an idiot and i mix up my lore about the game like all the fucking time right and i
couldn't remember what the actual recording movie lore was everyone is crying outside this mountain
over gandalf but what it was is they hadn't like done the scene so they were crying over nothing
basically they hadn't really met gandalf's character at all at this recording stage
because they tried to get all of the outdoor footage stuff done so in the movie they're all
greeting over gandalf and they've not even met them yet basically so don't tell me they weren't good
actors in the movie they were greeting over we don't want any orc it's like the same uh the
scene with um rider um or argon and uh the pub for the first time he was an emergency standing um
he was an emergency standing uh because their original person that was going to play argon
got yoinked because they did a few scenes with them and then peter jackson was like yeah this
isn't gonna work out so in the pub scene where he's like smoking his wee cigarette that's not him
and then when he does get revealed in the scene he's just being impromptued by like what the others
are doing type thing like they're actually not in the scene together why are you crying i don't know
who are you didn't that make ian mckellan because he wanted to interact with people yes in the hobbit
um because of the height difference instead of using practical stuff like they did in the first
movie they used like stunt doubles all of that he was literally in a room filled with green screens
talking to tennis balls with faces on it and he was like i can't do this um so peter jackson like
tried to cheer him up um like they pimped out his little studio caravan room thing like he put loads
of props in it to like cheer him up because he likes the elven props um it was just kind of one
of those like really unfortunate things where like ian mckellan he wants to act with other people
he's fantastic for the stage he's fantastic for socializing and it just felt so wrong for him to
be a room on his own like reading his lines to no one um and it just felt awful oh my god if that
ain't my little sister emmy bezu and the pin pals hi what shenanigans did you get up to dany be
worried um did i need to be worried about the pin pals what shenanigans were you getting up to in
there what were you doing you goofy gubbers we're getting rated i am playing leg lord of the rings
and a mildly geeking out i'm being i'm being pretty well behaved we were playing poppy's
play time part three i've not played part three so me watching you play it in times two so i
know what to do when i play it did you manage to finish it or is the game really awkward to finish
no i was gonna try and go for the map stone in the background oh well oh we're getting a little
dance little ceremony as we enter we kissed a lot we hi readers hi pin pals i hope you had a fun
time did emmy get scared did you scream we didn't finish no this cannot be isn't it difficult
um because i played poppy's play time and i think the quest she did she screamed oh am i
that's i'm getting highly real of her screams who has a cute scream and be allure and it's just emmy
going ah it's so hard okay maybe i'm not playing at all fuck that fuck that she ain't playing that
the whole christopher lee is gambo what no isn't christopher lee
why did i get a sticker for want to stay
glad you can say we're unlocking equipment so we can do more
i don't remember is there a screaming did you play poppy's play ball
it's puzzles and platform man fuck that shit i ain't doing IQ test in the middle of a game what the
fuck okay don't worry i have your rage from blinks bro i've raged on two games james camera's avatar
and blink so far is like when i'm like assy red oh we're going on a romantic boat ride when the moon
hits your eye like a big piece of pie that's a boring
christopher lee is there i'm like oh why did i forget his name as if i don't know that sorry i
don't know why i'm thinking of a legless's dad is it chris evans or something like that i'm so bad
what actor's names congrats if your name's chris by the way oh my god about your cream and your
little pannier ones i just really strongly what your thoughts on tabletop rpgs that feature in
horses of small stature uh gen four horse girl sure knock yourself out that's what you're asking
i don't know wait oh lee pay all right i'm terrible what actor's names don't ask me nothing okay don't
ask me for anyone's name we're about to finish the first movie yeah zebra yeah sure fucking gen
four anything you want gen four is all yours you guys can pick everything you want for gen four
knock yourself up yep well the vote whoever gets top six will be made yep that's exactly who we're
gonna do for gen four christopher lee is also the only actor who played in the movies that personally
met polkin yeah i remember the behind the scenes he gets stabbed and he was like um actually peter
jackson this is what you do when you get stabbed and then peter jackson was like i got put in my
place not gonna lie which is so good which is so good oh you want to slime yeah gen four
slam girl gen four yeah phew knock yourself out they made a movie based on these games
stop because you're mad ah boromir he's getting corrupted he's getting corrupted boromir no get
off get off of me i'm sorry there's a tabletop rpg real set that i think that people could do
it may threaten to convert the pin pals into a pony and you think she won't do it you think she's
bluffing uh i'm gonna say i'm gonna say no she's not bluffing so you better listen to her okay
i don't care if she's younger than you i'm gonna fuck you need to start listening to your little
sister okay are you gonna get turned into a little pony oh skinny and bony okay always be in my heart
what am i doing in this one sorry i've kind of this mission i actually forget often where
that all the things are so don't be surprised that we have to replay this for like that billion
freaking time because this one sucks if you don't see you need a mithril bow and arrow in order to
shoot that because even in free play um wait is it spelled shon like i shon big i thought his name
was the actor's name is shon shon for boromir but then can we have saruman and jen sure yeah
whatever you guys want you can get anything for gentle or not here so
can i just walk past them beat everything up all right there we go
i can hear something behind these steps so i'm gonna see if i can reach it
oh god not the rainbow dash shot it's nope no we're not doing that okay we can reach this one
without having to do it i could hear it shining i'm like we might as well try and go for it um
brodo i'm sorry
um
so i don't remember this one much so i'm like try to take a 10 oh i know what it is you
have to do the catapult twice or some piss it's so silly this one's so silly okay i said it's so
um but the good news is sam has unlocked mithril rope now and frodo has a light source i've
forgotten his name i'm so sorry for the hardcore lord of the rings ones i'm sorry i'm just the
casual lord of the rings fans it's you know okay pop goes to me though imagine a gimley girl you
want it you just want to be together with a beard but it's like still a girl just randomly has like
a beard that they can toggle on and off for the hell of it come gimley for a little bit
the creature the creature among the among us poster oh no it's potion are there any female
dwarf feature birds i mean if they want to be lore accurate they need a beard so i'm not sure how
many would do that can't can't guarantee success you know
but it is in fact not a beard oh no what is it am i fake lord of the rings fan i might be
i actually sorry i just do it for male attention i pretend to enjoy lord of the ring for male
attention stop because someone's gonna believe me for those of you who are listening in and don't
understand sarcasm i enjoy lord of the rings very much i like to see the sentence that i do things
for male attention when really i just like it and it just happens to be something we might have in
common i'm very sarcastic when i say that out loud and i understand not everyone can pick up on
sarcasm that's perfectly fine i'm just saying here right now i'm memeing when i say i do it for male
attention i promise you when i make pregnancy asmr i get something out of it as well okay i'm
not just like some some fucking mastermind like oh yeah um yeah you know i'm a bit late for that
what am i doing up here ah a rock of course there was a rock up here of course the rock is what's
gonna um whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa back off back off get off me yeah bro get off me
yeah i'll shank you now and in it get off me don't ever do that again where are you going okay right
i get it go up there jeez you're jumping me man you're jumping me get up get up um
um
i still remember the xbox lord of the ring game that only covered till the helm state the fight
and the combat was so fun i have terrible news for the hobbit so i do want to play lego hobbit
for some reason it just ends they did the first two movies and then the game just ends in the
hobbit we are gonna play it because i do enjoy it but the third movie is just straight up not in the
video game no it's not dlc no the reason was never publicly released but i think it's obvious
warner brothers were being a bunch of fannies um i'll shank you now honestly there's a lego hobbit
to yes but it's definitely not as popular due to the nature of the medical emergency in that game
oh my god i am forgetting everything in this game uh uh uh what do i need to i don't know i don't
know i don't know i don't know what i need to i need to beat these up i'll beat these up right
now and look i won't right there's a fireplace okay that's good i need a torch perfect we're doing
it right this area you can't literally do nothing in until you get like the free play mode
that's part of it they couldn't get the license and it's all warner brothers and mass corporations
so you know what we say about the high table ruining it for everyone they do be ruining it
you're you're ruining it you're ruining it okay i'm gonna see if i can play the lord of the rings
game like that old ancient one i have never played it personally but everyone recommends it if you're
a lord of the rings fan so i think we're gonna play it for the first time i get nervous to play
a game for the first time though i don't know if i'm allowed to cheat to doodle and play like one
hour offline and then then be like yeah that's all good okay i've messed up because i didn't do it
on the other character but it's fine you'll have to talk to me what do you mean you don't you don't
do it for attention mommy i thought you were a master better honestly i will be soon probably soon
soon you're not even gonna know what to do with your winky when the old twitter gets uh gets
updated but now right now i'm too stressed i'm ready to combust i ain't gonna make it chief
i ain't gonna make it at this rate i ain't gonna make it it was it was a good run it really was
at a good time but i'm literally yoda in bed right now where he just like where looks sky walkers
looking at yoda and he's like right good night and then he just fucking disappears into nothing
that's me right now i'm like i can't make it it's not good there is a hidden item to the right here
i'm gonna do it now in case i forget when i'm doing my yapping when we replay this section
combust but not in the good way so new audio soon so patreon's getting an update i'm doing the funny
ha ha one but here is the hidden one it's really awkward don't you be spamming my pregnancy i'm
what young man you already want to go back inside my body i've not even wrote the bore one yet i
need to go commission the bore artwork actually i want to work with the same person again because
they made me so cute and they literally gave me the option of what i wanted and i'm like bro i want
to work with you again so but you were like so professional for no reason like i gave you the
most unhinged commission and you were so professional like what the hell oh my there's no way up next
unburdening smart what's that is that where i put you inside me like on purpose i was just going to
do you go in my tummy there's an enemy that comes out from underneath here by the way it just
randomly attacks you whilst you're minding your own business if you go under that i'm just warning
you now don't be caught off guard because he always catches me off guard but we can skip them
you want to go back in the womb no i can put you in my tummy but i don't know how i can do
anything further like i'm unburdened okay aragon more like your smell alone because you're smelling
so aragon fucking thing is he can track stuff obviously because he's a hunter in that but you
need to like follow the stupid green thing around and it's such a busted system it's so busted like
it's literally telling me to walk on this damn statue like no motherfucker i can't walk on the
damn statue but then the more you like walk around in circles like the less the distance gets
type thing where is the rig it has taken barmy barmy shan't get it isn't it just more with extra
parts would you destroy well well there'd be a sequel how am i supposed to sequelize a pregnancy
audio the fucking birth room ASMR getting a c-section ASMR what i don't know how i'm supposed
to sequel pregnancy i have to admit this is out of my experience range you know there's a lot i
can do but there's some stuff i ain't got so you need to kill the guys on the pedestals in order
to progress i took me a very long time in my first playthrough to figure that out anyone that's on a
pedestal or like stationary get them gone and then you can progress birth and then unbirth to make
a trilogy i mean that's the logic could be a funny short instead of a whole video i'll
um right as i said so he's now down but that sniper to the left he has to go or we cannot progress
unfortunately that platform is on me thrill so we can't do anything with it yet explain unlock the
character for me so that destroys me throw but then again boom next area unlock so nice and simple
kind of um kind of easily explainable tactics um
uh right we'll have to toss him i actually didn't see that to be honest i don't know what
unbirth you get mad and say all right you're going back in the womb that's actually girlfriend
gets so mad at you she she like puts you back in the womb and like you sit there and think about
it since you want to act like a fuck it since you want to act like a fucking baby oh hold on a minute
you might actually be working on something you might be cooking hold on a minute you might be
cooking with the ship post an angle because you know that's for me baby um girlfriend arguing
with your girlfriend ace more and put you back in the womb or something how would our name that
though i would have to have you put me in my womb since you want to act like a fucking child
and okay i'm cooking then you let me cook because this is what happens this is what happens when
you let me cook come out with the most bizarre conflicts i still need to write uh ace marse uh
ace marse hypnosis hypnotizes you into liking pineapple on pizza i'm so excited i'm so excited
i just can't hate it right look at the look at the statue what is he holding the freaking
instructions to let me through where i've been pushed off outside and i'm allowed to be pushed off
oh
they do keep the humor even in the sad scenes well
girlfriend takes you back to the minute fondle abyssal is what happened and when stroney get
literally that's why i'm not allowed on the development team anymore kicked off of my own
development team feels bad man feels bad man that's how badly i kicked that have been kicked off the
team you think uh you think i'm kidding as well no uh i'm literally not allowed to name any of the
girls for any future i was literally that bad i was literally that bad karambi in fondle abyssal
name wonder i got kicked off uh that's all i'm saying name wonder i got kicked off
naming perms revolt literally i'm allowed to do some other stuff but i'm not really allowed to
hyper do it anymore and i'm like you know what i deserve that i deserved it okay i deserve that
i'm a naughty belly i'm not a belly i'm a naughty yellow i have a broom in my chest
because i'm sweeping up these enemies hold on let me just reach for the badoon
thank you thank you i'll be here
sorry and then we're gonna beat him up and then we're done
i'm sorry ever the cola was in the way so it was a delayed badoon
it was a delayed badoon
it was a delayed badoon now you can sweep up all the puke moment real not the banana
what it's a chicken no way the chicken's what perishes him the egg no not the egg
potassium the only weakness wait what happens in this fight i don't remember
bro uh what do i do he throws the shield he comes and picks up and then goes away again
i mean she if you're gonna make it that easy for me see this is why i love the lego game sorry
i love them it's it's so fun okay it's so easy it's so straightforward if you've played it before
like sorry i'm sorry these are just like really well polished games sorry these are 10 out of 10
games you can't tell me the other way uh don't think i won't do a lego lord of the rings review
when i start doing my reviews in october don't think i won't do it don't think i won't do it
so like see so is it and then we beat him up we jump him jump him and then he's gonna summon more
straightforward unlike blink okay we do not speak of the b word in this chat anymore okay it's forbidden
i forbade you i forbade you i will hypnotize you to forget that stream because it's absolutely
awful sorry i was actually region it's five o'clock in the morning i'm not trying to do frame perfect
attacks i'm sorry i will defend myself to my shit gameplay i'm not doing frame perfect attacks
first thing in the morning like what what am i what am i what am i doing the news
like honest why am i getting fucking picked up like
okay did he just keep picking us up we just just picking us up and we're like wall
wallop wallop wallop um oh my god
the little ones they take the red plane
my little ones
uh
another emmy eyes oh i just realized emmy's eyes are also dead eyes
because she only has eyes for her dead brother oh stop did i just unlock emmy lore concept artists
did i just stumble upon lore by accident be honest i stumble upon their lore like their
their concepts by accident because she only has eyes for her dead brother
that would kind of be cool and added to the world oh
come on the fellowship didn't last too long unfortunately
oh no oh no we're in trouble we're in trouble
do you recall the funny scene this is the scene exactly the scene that this one's coming up next
is foul it's absolutely foul what comes up next i'm just warning you now so if you're
tuning out if you want to giggle tune in for like the next two minutes um because this is
ridiculous what you're about to witness
it makes me happy another fun fact about this movie is that every actor tried to kiss each other
actor in the cast i'm a lot wanted to kiss third way would you kiss me that was in the cat
um
mythril rope not bad we have a whole six mythril seven mythril to design
stuff and make stuff and
continue story
okay this is the scene
so
absolutely foul foul a fucking ping pong down the river like ding ding ding as if he was like
a game of pachinko
hello i do like him like locking and loading his axe pinballed him literally
honestly me if we ever went on an adventure reef and i'd be like i'm tired please
i'm so weak i'd be like oh my puny little wrists so we did it we finished the first movie only
two more to go but we did it thank you travelers tale for making one of the greatest games of all
time yay he pumped his axe like a show yeah but we did it on messy so now we're gonna enter movie
number two done done done i will gladly carry your load wait a minute
nine percent complete let's go we're doing so well
i'd happily drag you down the path by the ankles free of charge naturally
so if you look now that we have like the ring and mythril we
map our hearts on frodo at the top left are like kind of protected a bit now so you can still
perish as frodo don't get me wrong you can still perish real quick um but yeah if we check out the
map we are um we're currently coming up to the black swamp and then we're gonna make it to the
black gate and more door but the other teammates also have to come into play it gets very creative i
really like it i like what they do here i'll point it out when we get to the section first
movie done three movies nine percent um what the spruce oh my god is that minecraft reference
you mean the spruce tree from minecraft you mean the sakura blossom tree like those things from
minecraft what they're based after real world what are you talking about me just touch an
binding of isaac reference this whole cottage core supply going on please um i've been influenced
golem the only time i've been influenced is by lord of the rings i just want a little farm or a
little community and we all like grow nice flowers and we all share our produce with each other so
we don't have to pay for basic living experiences and stuff i don't know very controversial i know
controversial very controversial so i won't i won't bring it up again i won't bring it up again
everyone wants to be a hobbit literally it's why i'm obsessed i'm like a little hobbit and
there's a map in lego um hobbit which i love so much because you get to go into the back garden
and bag end and i just want to sit out there in the back garden and enjoy bag ends for all we've got
so yandel this is the most annoying treasure to ever if you do not do this
stair sequence correctly you will be denied the treasure okay but moving items around in this
game with magic sucks okay as much as i like sucking on the willy right this sucks if you
don't do it right and it's so see how like sensitive and stuff is it is and it's so delayed right i'm
going to purposefully put it up there okay if i need to do this right easy eat nope see we're
fucked up just the john thank you for the 10 and do we stick our thing with glicks i like it
thank you for the 10 we must we have to be frame perfect hold on yep easy easy
nope nope okay this is a freaking problem we will not unlock the treasure if we don't do this frame
perfect okay there we go and we're gonna slot it oh it's tight it's tight is anyone got loop
it's tight holy go up and go no right okay we're moving the yellow one out the way a little bit
why would you not fit in please fit oh go down right hold on it may be easier to move that to the
side easy steady okay okay okay don't don't give up yet okay don't let mm-hmm mm-hmm okay um
okay yes okay we did it we don't ever have to do that again you can skip these height puzzles
by literally slapping two on top but we did it we did it okay and thank you for letting me
pop your your super chat cherry we did it we will never have to do that again okay it's an
absolute nightmare it took me so long to figure out what the last hidden item was in this game that
i couldn't find but i remember all the good and all the bad in this game i promise you i promise
i do i'm just i'm just that mlg pro sorry when other streamers are being top 500 in video games me
i'm sweating on lego lord of the rings you haven't you haven't worked a hard day in your life okay
soft hands brother soft hands streamer you ain't you ain't putting a seven hour shift on lego
lord of the rings i assure you that much you haven't gone against a balrog with perfect no hit okay
okay now this fight could be sped up a little bit that's my only developmental note it could
be sped up a bit we're gonna be here for a solid two minutes um but overall we will uh get through
it nice and easy shaft hands brother i love that meme you ain't worked a hard day in your life soft
hands brother and like their hands are like covered in dirt and they're eating their food without
washing them in that it's like a big old move big old brain rot mean if you're not into the
brain rot side things um so basically i against all odds as if the the camera isn't trying to
tell you that hey there's a thing here um we actually want to stand in the lightning now
i do want to assure you for those reeflings who uh might not be so um
um you know you may be uh a little you know just yourself uh a little bit too much of a
reefling do not play in lightning do not wear metallic items during a thunderstorm of that
nature um do not be a magnet if you will to the electricity is very dangerous okay i want the
best for you i want you to be safe all right i work 47 hours a day you got soft hands boy see
you know the meme okay again we walk in the lightning wherever it strikes here we go and
we press b and then we lift up the thing in for the legal piece that's on display but playing in
traffic is all right i don't know why that's the thing who needs to be told not to play in traffic
it's my question but then i discovered that scotland isn't like other countries where there's like a
park pretty much in every uh town village city uh district whatever you want to call it like there's
always one there i was so late on that jump and we didn't get hurt i don't know how um
but yeah so apparently parks aren't a thing everywhere universally who'd have fun that's
where to see where's it gonna be oh i pressed the wrong button embarrassing you didn't see that
i pressed x okay you must i'll i'll tell you everything let's go if you want me to be safe
from here make sure standing in lightning shocking behavior my cola was in the way again i'm sorry
it was a delayed reaction the cola was in the way the can of cola is getting put to my right i
repeat the can of cola is getting put to my right because it's taking too long for me to hit that
dang thing to make the joke funny the delay is what kills it okay fishy time fishy time
golems hungy we need to feed golem because we feed all the reeflings yes golems are reefling as
well just because he looks a bit different it doesn't mean he's you know and he's a wee bit
bad but you don't you don't necessarily have to you know get it perfect so what we do is we pick
up the fish and we throw it in the bucket and then it oh sorry hold hold on a minute and we throw it
in the bucket and then it low the weight of it actually lowers the wall now i promise you you're
not catching fish that are that heavy in real life unless it's like tuna or something uh wait
that shouldn't happen so we use sam to get up and then we beat these up so they release the
ladders and then that's already got the third fishing he's a model reefling our strongest
soldier our most feral soldier honestly i think if you beat up the bones you get an
a treasure possibly didn't beat up all the bones on the map oh that's one of four um as i said
sam now has a rope and if rhodo can now go in dark spaces with the magic fail we need sam to come
over so you do need to like work in tangent and unison with one another um especially for things
like this like Frodo uh sam can get stuck in the um he can get stuck in caves and stuff if you're
not careful which is a little bit annoying but it is what it is uh we can beat this up a piece of
desire so we'll go for it strongly giving our toughest battles to the strongest reeflings honestly
i'm just joining the first person to the level one hitless legals i've already been beating up
like so many i think uh the biggest danger to myself in video games is well for the type of
games that i play anyway it isn't the enemies it's me perishing off the map and like falling off the
map and stuff um because yeah i i don't know i just seem to be my biggest enemy when it comes to
games now we are gonna make a fire with sam so we do need to grab this piece so oh i just dropped
the fish please let me pick it back up again i hate when the game does that it gives me a heart attack
it gives me a heart attack you must hate platformers i am not good at them so i avoid them like i've
been very tactical in my game choices um when streaming but as i said blinks is the first
game that i've been like that was a terrible idea who picked that game because it was me it was me
um but yes i messed up with that but i try to pick games i know i'm gonna like or i have a
genuine interest in playing for the first time um but platformers to me are just like really
frustrating i didn't get it didn't get it i don't know why like so like the elden ring is one of
those games where i would never play on my own but because you guys have the ability to literally
carry me in stream snipe i have so much fun because i like being able to play games with
you um it just feels like so much better and like fun when like we get to do stuff together
um uh i'm still not sure what to do about fortnite metal pants i think we will end up playing it
but eddy's would be nice um eddy's would be nice so we need to get frodo to come up to do this thing
blinks tried is blinks or not platformer i don't think it's a platformer but it was a game
that is not for me yes let's beat this up so i think we can get the fourth one wherever it is
i'm not sure but it is frodo has to go up here into this bit because there's a little fishy in
that dark and then we got all the fishes and then we're on to the next part away see we got two
fishes each so sam has two i have to um crash bandicoot as a platformer and you enjoyed it i mean
it was relatively easy going around in circles okay let's make sure the game doesn't randomly
throw the fish halfway across the map and we have to get it again because i have to admit
this game is a little naughty for that if you have an item it might not auto lock on where
you're wanting to put it and i'm like um okay let's go wait a spiral platformer too senior
rage against is funny though i mean as long as you're enjoying it but i'm fucking raging in that
moment i'm raging and when i'm raging i feel like i get like become like such a moody demon
and i'm like no one wants to watch someone be raging at a video game like you know those games
that are like jump king oh my i could not even imagine how loud i'd be screaming at jump king
i don't know how people tolerate it i don't know how they enjoy it i don't know what enjoyment you
get out of it because like the endorphin drop that i would get in the mood swings i would get
playing a game like that like it's just punishing i don't know how anyone has the enjoyment of
tolerance etc for it a very small full of rage anger literally you know what one how dare you two
that's me uh oh we're getting a free treasure chest i'm not arguing i'm not arguing
okay free treasure chest right first things first let's speak golem we give him one fishy
and then i think he attacks us actually he does right okay we need to like i think he attacks sam
and then we need to beat him up or something
wait what was that yeah that okay that was it and then we beat him up and then that's one hp
off of them okay oh and we beat up sam while we're at it as well sorry he deserved it he's asking for
they're such a cute image rage i feel like you guys will get scared when we want to rage you're
like oh my god what's wrong with her and i'm just like hey it's 5 am in the morning
okay we are gonna put a fishing rod together and we just need to combine it
a rope and a hook what did you call me okay we don't have the last part yeah i think we need to
climb up here or something can we make a little staircase oh uh wait what how'd i go oh sometimes
the easiest solution is the the obvious you know instead of making things off we're gonna say
the fishing rods on Frodo though okay this is where i could fart on the game so i have the stick
that Frodo needs okay so i need to drop it and make sure it doesn't despawn or go halfway across
the map hey that this fishing rod does actually account for an item which is pretty cool i think
it's pretty cool anyway but we're cooking and catching a fish don't make Johnny angry you
wouldn't like when she's angry it looks really so he's gonna fish that up i'm gonna throw it to
little Gordon um and i'm gonna get do the rope thing i'll get attacked and then some
hey Frodo will save us and then that's it this sequence is done he's gonna get attacked
and then we save we swoop in and save the day boom boom and then we do the fishing thing again
i'm like 99 percent yeah that's literally the exact same thing i do like this i think uh
because it's enjoyable although the game looks like a pixel on the wall back there i don't know
if it's because it's nighttime go go go i want to witness the rage live what you want a rage
stream i don't know if i could mentally prepare to rage on stream
you've seen it before haven't you haven't you go
me when i can't get your ink for the eighth time in a row a drunk stream
i i don't want to upset anyone but my house has been declining and i don't think i can
have any alcohol at the minute until it improves because i seem to have like faster heartbeat
when i drink alcohol and stuff so no drunk stream from me anytime soon possibly from the girls though
yeah um
but yeah don't worry everything's fine right last time to exercise 20 30s course um i am going
to try and do two ring fit streams in a month and i have been trying to walk and make aim i've been
eating like healthier as well like yesterday i had that chicken pie with veggies and an egg
so it was just like pure protein none of that bad shit like um i'm trying to cut my takeaway
because at the end of stream i'm just so tired the last thing i want to do is like go cycle to the
shop um or go and like make myself to or whatever and i'm just like oh it's just easier just do
takeaway you know the food arrives to me i don't have to think about it i can put it all in the
rubbish you know healthy waifu happy life let basically is what i'm trying to do right now
i'm trying to be better for myself um and you know it just takes time obviously the first time i've
ever really been in this kind of job role aspect so it was natural that things weren't going to be
straightforward um and find myself out of time but as i said there's progress hams um chicken
salad basically i'm making i'm making chicken soup next week and i'm so excited i know it sounds
so like nerdy or whatever but i'm so excited to make chicken soup i love soup um and i like all
the veggies in it and i'm gonna get um what are they called it's not the goons it's like the
the the thing you soak in water overnight and then you put it in a soup oh my god
i'd love to work out with mum every now and then watching ring fit streams healthy reflings produce
more rink for mama true and real um thank you strongy's little refling and such a cute name
thank you for the size um yes i am going to focus um in august to take my health a bit
more seriously right this is an absolute nightmare of a map i'm actually in advance
going to lower the volume so please what did i just do it's not that um i am going to artificially
lower the volume you will understand very shortly why i'm doing this now i will raise it at the end
of this mission lentils yeah yeah lentils i'm gonna do like soak lentils overnight i'm gonna
make a batch of soup i'm gonna show you i think because i'm gonna be so proud of it and so happy
and um we got another item a wooden bucket unlocked and are you squidding me right now
anonymous you didn't even say anything you just gave me money did you forget to take the
and no don't send me another one saying no i didn't forget to take the message
thank you for your kind tip okay i'll take it i'll take your silent message as your interest in
uh me making chicken soup okay you want some chicken soup too cooking stream let's go well
i'm doing a hand cam poppin cooking because emmy sorry emmy's been inspiring i'm like
sorry let me just pinch that idea real quick um because her rat one was absolutely adorable so
i'm gonna leave my door open and do it on the floor and gimley and vego are gonna come in well i assume
they're gonna come in because all they do is try and batter down my door and and before it's the one
stream they have absolutely no interest in being around me and everyone's gonna be like your cats
hate you and i'm gonna be like yeah i know i know i'm away but yeah i'm gonna try it see how it goes
there's a shredded raw carrots pickle cucumber and sugar
um yeah um oh wait i'm out of water right frodo needs to stand on oh don't do that frodo
needs to stand on this and then sam needs to walk over because he's got the pale
not to be confused with the pale the location in skyrim which is a province of the map
um yeah i make chicken soup next week this week i'm having nothing but chicken pie and vegetables
and eggs i'm getting like all that back in my system and then i'm gonna work i don't have a
problem eating vegetables like i've never had a problem um god shut the fuck up no cares okay um
um literally like what are you even talking about what are you even spitting down the mic about
anyway let's think of more
because what's on here oh hey i care no please ramble more okay if you like the ramble and
that's fine but i'm like brov brov honestly get a clue get a clue oh okay don't move frodo do
you understand don't move a muscle okay and then the week after i'm gonna focus on getting loads
of fruit back in my tummy again um because i drink uh these like fruit blended up fruit drinks which
i think really help and all that um work is born as hell right now right yeah how do we space up
someone that wait can you see the screen if you're at work right now or can i just pretend like stuff
has happened oh my god did you see oh my god oh my god oh you missed it you missed it because
you were at work and you weren't looking at the screen because you're busy having to look elsewhere
oh i'm so sorry you missed that oh no it won't work on the rewind sorry it's not going to work on
the rewind you missed how evil is that that's so evil why why really i'm an evil siren i've
proved that i'm immediately peeking see see it works it's only being a little shit literally
can't overstate how much soup is a lifesaver made a massive amount of fortnight ago and froze
ended up having a health scare last week that left me very stressed and short on time that soup
literally kept me alive for a week also smooth or oh thank you for that i'm glad to hear that you're
feeling a bit better i think i'm probably in your shoes right now um oh my god we're literally
you had a health scare i had a health scare we should like make it or something i don't know
um i'm going to say something controversial okay so don't cancel me but chunky soup is where it's at
i want to bite that liquid okay i want to take a nice bite into a juicy chunky yummy carrot okay
i want to feel them legumes slop down my throat okay uh and then i want nice white crusty bread on
the side what more could i ask for okay straining nor no why would you want smooth soup how evil
are you lore wise absolutely despicable i want to destroy all of humanity but well i say unfortunately
lore wise not the best but um other than that um
other than that the reeflings helped me and i have seen the light now that i have received
a good inking right this is why we've muted this this dragon screams this entirety like of the entire
sequence it is absolutely awful this ring race this dragon it screams the entire time and it's so loud
so i have put down the in-game volume but i will put it up next level because this is the only level
that has this issue it is so aggravating especially when you're trying to do a hundred percent completion
oh my goodness golly it is so loud it is so loud i want to grab that no no no that's for sam that's
for sam sam yep sam do your thing me do this sweet i'm just a plant please leave me alone
the nascar looks scuffed i mean they did all right with what they had but i'll give you more ink if
you want some real entry did you just die instantly yes it takes all of your health in one go you do
not survive you lose all your weak points that you try so hard to gather um is a bit frustrating
honestly if you want to like get real Frodo don't do that again i'm scared
you're doing thank you anonymous and thank you in case i'm not shingin it
is the main attack tactic of the dragon a silent dragon the weak one
i might just fill the millets about he looks so chonky he a chonky mo
um
almost there we're almost there
again you need to like literally tell them to go in these or else they won't and they'll
perish themselves and it's like please ai work with me here i'm trying my hardest work with you here
it's the best invincibility effect i've ever oh okay this is the problem if you mess up that
sequence and do it too early he has to like come back and do it all over again bra i got too excited
okay i got too excited i was premature in my movements we've been we've had this conversation
before one in three men okay it's fine it's natural but i'm gonna grab this coin because uh
we are needing okay they can both hide in here both sam and brodo sam just needs to come under
okay that's all good that's all good oh is the bush timed no no i moved out of the bush too quickly
why does the water change when golem goes through it is he pooping no it's a marsh it's a bog
so the sediment on the bottom of the i know you're just making a joke sorry sorry i'm literally
like a mother when you tell like your mama joke and then she like turns it into a lesson randomly
i'm so sorry i'm like randomly turning it into a lesson i'm like so the sediment stays at the
bottom of the bog it's why like a lot of preserved um historical things are because where the where am i
trying to go oh sam it's the reason why a preservation in a bog because it doesn't get
stirred up or anything like that it's actually really fascinating like how we've got preserved
there was i can't remember there was a girl that was pulled out of a bog like 100 years ago and
they legit thought she popped her clogs maybe 200 years ago max from when she was discovered
and it was like no she is like preserved like a thousand year old plus i can't remember i might
have been swedish maybe i don't know there's a lot of discoveries like in scotland as well we have
quite quite a few bogs um because of the climate and all that jazz it is faster to move through
this via jumping um rather than weeding through the the bog honestly lessons with strony and random
things you know it's always a good time okay so mameco did that break i hide like that sam goes
in here and then i go in frodo because sam won't jump out but for some reason frodo will keep
changing i don't know why it's just don't don't question the ai the ai's a bit still silly in
this one there's a lot of bog bodies in ireland too yeah yeah because of the the scottish climate
you hit 19 000 oh okay now are we
i don't i don't even know what to say about the asmar debt i'm gonna be honest chief
i don't even know what to say i don't even know what to say soon that's what i'm gonna say you know
what's soon fuck you soon thank you so much for all the support everyone who's liked subscribe
i am i know i'm in debt i know i'm in debt to you i'm gonna say soon okay i'm gonna say soon
what do you mean the pregnancy asmar threw me ahead a couple of hundred subscribers
crazy crazy
okay we did it we did it i'm happy to listen to whatever you say because my dad's Scottish as
well and but i lost his accent oh i was worried if i would lose my accent coming to australia
well um no that certainly did not happen i was embedded in me i can't change it and especially
the australian accents were really hard to mimic been here like two years or something now quite
a while now uh yeah the um the um the what the what um it's too hard the only thing i can do is the
news channel and it's it's like if anything it's a parody of the australian accent like
and on tonight's news down from down under like it's so bad it's so bad if you lose your accent
it's so ogre well the only thing that might happen is it would mash a bit with ozzy but i
can't imagine it like i can't imagine how an ozzy would say like dinny canny will need like i can't
yeah i just can't imagine this this thing and i've actually been introducing my accent slightly
more on streams i've been a little bit naughty and not being very not being not using slang i've
been using it a wee bit more and because i'm turning you scottish with me one way or another
either with consent or without it doesn't matter when it comes
scottish with an ozzy accent combo would be wild it would be pretty right there slowly conditioning
us real i'm true uh right we need to do the ollie fans so we can jump up on the ropes that come
awesome now you can actually just ignore what was right you can just ignore these guys on the lower
quadrant if you so desire because the main thing is if you perish this guy and then i think that
ollie fans goes down it is before you're like why are you saying elephant like that it is
referred to as ollie fan in the books and in the movie um then again just do the exact same thing
it's not an issue not problem you can just if i can if i can reach hello okay there we go i was
like i'm a wee bit too small for this one again uh yeah you can literally just ignore all that fight
and just be fun to the boss you want an american accent well boy howdy do i have an american accent
for y'all i'd like to get a cup of water um see i was actually thinking about the tri-state area
that i live in i had got contacted by the h a o um and i didn't cut my lawn my my front yard was a
little overgrown so i had to get my lawn mower out and then i went down to applebee's um and then
it was tax season so i had to go and guess how much tax i had to i'm sorry i was at h oi sorry
oh and i forgot to take my flint stone gummies this morning yeah i forgot to do that and then
i added a stick of butter into my breakfast i'm sorry that's the best i've got why applebee's
applebee's is like i don't know or cracker barrel cracker barrel always gets the trash state area
always gets brought up and and it's like all right like i went to speak to the there's like
some terminology for something that goes on in college in america that's not a thing anywhere
else i keep forgetting slate those flint stone gummies yeah only one stick to do cutting it back
cutting back okay that's like you done good if you said yelch oh yeah sorry i have to go fix up
my vehicle and then later i'm gonna cook and use some herbs in my food my food instead of
herbs even though it's got h but when it comes to vehicle it's just a heckle you want i'll do
the new york accent don't think i won't do it again don't think i won't do the new york accent
hey i'm walking here i'm playing lord of the ringsy mate well that was just straight up a parody of
england um i can't do it for this i cannot save myself the best i got is cream from uh sonic
sonic
not the accent of my people i actually i'm a new i'm gonna get me a hot dog when i come down at
the airport in new york and i'm gonna get a taxi and then i'm gonna go to new time square
and then i'm gonna get a cheese and ham roll with the orange juice because of jaylo
she randomly went with the orange juice you know you oh i'm going to a bossy aga no a bianca
oh my god a bodega i'm gonna go i'm going to a bodega i'm doing all the american things in a
bodega and there's gonna be a bodega cat at the bodega and you get to pet it and stuff
i got there in the end in the uk it's just called a corner shop but it's called a bodega
for some reason what's that it's like a corner shop they sell drinks they sell food you can also
get a sandwich if you want sorry the horses are doing a little dance right now it's quite cute
me
where the what's that they're doing dressage the horses are doing the creep walk
chat we're almost at the helmet thing prepare yourselves if you guys do not spam chat that he
did you know he no i meant you emphasize the h in the letter americans pronounce it more like
h i'll you uk and others say hey chum hands down that was the best football game i ever saw
oh this is not working this is not working hands down hands down
i'm trying i'm trying so hard i i do not mean to disappoint but i'm disappointing so badly
we have a winner never in my life would ever hear horses are creep walking oh my god you
haven't seen the meme i kid you not fuck this stream right now open up a new tab on youtube
and type in um type in um snoop dog reviews the olympics or something like that or the the
horses like the dressage snoop dog dressage something like that okay and he literally goes
that horse is doing the creep walk it is the funniest thing you absolutely adore the clip
it's funny literally you're all you all have permission to open up a tab and type in snoop
dog a dressage horse clip something like that is the funniest thing
literally he was like reviewing the olympics and he was at the olympics as well apparently he was on
tv again with aragon sentrial thing you have to like deal with it yeah it's a bit a bit rubbish
does that have a rope oh okay the game literally told me
and did you know vigo mortis and brookie no we're not there yet you have to do it on the scene
oh wait the scene's already occurred at this point oh no the scene's already occurred it's not in
it's not in the footage of the uh the game at this lore point i can move in the cutscene
aragon a temporal literally sent he sent training out the wazoo
he sent trained out the wazoo
um
as what what is this how is this a natural thing you said literally it's so fun
um you can completely skip this next area this is literally for like when you come back and do
freeplay um so you zoom past this area it's i can't remember if we actually have to do that
okay yeah we did this oh my god my we hats my hands are sweating sorry i i literally need a napkin
that's how intense this gameplay is for me because i love it so much that my hands are sweating so
badly i need a fucking napkin uh you got to get going don't worry thank you for hanging in
um okay okay see the ai is really it literally leads you to the left only to put you to the right
to redo it and then put you at the bushes even though the bushes was always the location
so lego games are hardcore literally you think it's hardcore that your streamers are doing
zero hit elden ring get on my level that's just true every day i can stress 20 instead of well
to play the wildest nostalgia game literally literally streaming is hard no it's not pick games
you love pick games that that you enjoy what you're worried that no one's going to show up for lego
lord of the ring what what are you talking about is like lord of the rings don't be so crazy don't
say such crazy things out loud you're speaking nonsense to me don't overthink it just have fun
so
astronomy is this better than blink yeah we don't say the b word around these parts do you
understand i'm not using the b word anymore
it's now the forbidden b word even though if you guys started typing about the b word i'll
completely forget what the b word is oh he's raging oh he's actual raging oh my god
excuse me for being a cute wee hobbit no i'm no fighting none of you just get away from me
weebam okay maybe i'm fighting you a little bit because i can't progress without fighting you
b word part two at 100 are you joking i wouldn't i'm not booting up that game
sorry i'm not booting up that game again i repeat i don't care
like i would literally need to sit and watch the tutorial first before i dared i'm just skipping
this fight because they will just keep fighting and it's like rock and skip all of this easiest
rage game of all time honestly shocking who said play that game we just need to get the wee
building materials oh there we go we did it claim claim tree beard did you know that
tree beard is voiced by gimley not my cat but the actual the actual gimley the real gimley
hi tree beard
did you hear that squish that
hobbit taking the hobbits to ice god
i didn't know that your knowledge on lord of the rings is so attractive oh yeah you're
getting you popping a bony over that i need to stop i'm getting high for it's because i'm playing
a game i enjoy okay i'm playing a game i enjoy i'm coming out with wild things i know i shouldn't
say such things but it can't help the diagram your cat is so talented literally i don't know how
she does it not only does she fart whenever i pet her so it goes right up my nostrils and
she also wait hold on we need to be triggered hold on tree beard time
i don't know if you heard my voice fail to make any noise when i went tree there
let's get boy into the news oh if i'm not mistaken oh right okay i'm just gonna do this one now if
there's like an awkward treasure i'm literally just gonna do it and get out of the way so we
need to throw a fucking rock at this i will don't ask why we just do do you want to aim for it
or are we just okay there we go i'm just gonna get this one out of the way because it's so
pernicki a bony a bow and arrow yes maybe so we need to go back and collect the boulder no
collect it oh it's bravo to collect it i'm being a silly sausage pick up pick up pick it up pick it up
pick it up right okay and now aim for the owl
and then we are going to go back and get the last one and then we never have to do this again
you're gonna play as tree beard yeah technically you your icon is placed on um mary but yeah we are
controlling them we're doing good we're just gonna break all this okay that's fine
and we are gonna throw one left we are gonna throw one left and then there we go don't have to do
that one again it's like your main control in the parasite so we need to grab him and then we walk
him across the river because he'll drown otherwise because he's so tiny but we don't want him to drown
so we're just gonna hurry up speed things along a bit and then drop him right here
he's cutting a tree oh no there's no way we can get past sure would be a shame if we could
figure a few things
and then so we're gonna extinguish the fire by breaking the tree
um there is it's not so secret but there is this over here if you want you can you need
a bow and arrow unfortunately but this is one of those kind of secret hidden areas that they do
that if you don't know it's there you're not gonna find it oh don't go into the light refling no
oh it's blinding it's a bit too dark in my room right now for this i have to admit
i'm fucking blinded i'm fucking i don't know about you back i see any of my sunglasses on
if you know you know he was fucking around with clownfish
track hobbit says level completo
i'll follow your voice instead of the light no refling don't die yet i still have use for you
many a milking ten reflings milking eight refling something uh five golden eight
three turtle dogs two french hens one partridge and a pear tree i do not know that one very well
is it on the first day of Christmas my driller sent to me it's not like that
fall lower wise following her death still leads to following her voice still leads to death
true oh my god my hands are like what the fuck my hands are sweating they're glistening right now
i don't know what's going on i think i need to take off my clothes i don't know why
no i don't know that's not right i'm gonna have to step up my hydration game i'm sitting here
has literally got my hands glistening because they wonder i'm hydrated been on pee all the time
all right there's clearly something all right with this body
right can i get a quick request in for a new one that'd be grand okay
same specifications as last time just remove the whatever the sweat gene is on me because
there's something all right here okay something all right here but reflings don't die it's strong
no i would never kill these what the heck do that
yes
oh sorry i'm just getting my blanket so i can put my knees on the table without
indenting them remove the tizm no everything needs to stay but the sweat gene needs to go
i know it's because of autism that sweat like this but it's really fucking annoying sometimes
it's been like shadow fact he's spent nothing but facts he defeats all the shadow box and you
need to do it because he's called shadow facts then time to go to rohan then
we have come on a long journey of 20 seconds
if it was even 20 seconds
reflings are safer and stronger nothing to worry about maybe turn the tizm off a bit
i'm i got the right sprinkle that lets me like push through stuff that others might not be able
to do um oh i've not put up the sound levels thank you for reminding me i will do it after the cutscene
i'll be quiet okay so you can hear the cutscene
so
sweaty hands and controllers mix bad like literally it's so uncomfortable and annoying
i'm hoping i cool down a bit now that i've taken my my armor off
not part of no man from his walking stick
he literally went these are not the droids you're looking for
hydration check
hmm warm tongue
he really hit him with a gritty have a 360 no scope
back off your woman
they say don't sweat the small stuff must be gamers are a big deal
okay option audio one one two three i think i was on six before tell me if there's too much
though right gimley smash nope oh wait he doesn't have his weapon try so uh what do i do
what i do i don't know what i do hold on hold on i need to try and remember right we don't
have a regular weapons which is fine i think we just destroy the enemies and then we like catch
him in a cage i managed to soft walk myself in this room one time i'm not gonna do it again
that's embarrassing right fire we can't do anything with right you know what i'm just working on take
this you little sheep oh it worked
huh right fucking exercise that motherfucker
okay
i will draw you saruman this poison is drawing from
i love
okay so we need to fucking cage him now yes okay i remember we literally need to cage him we
are about to she be this man right now get she beats get she beats get she beats plop plop plop
get she beats get she beats okay so wallop him and then wait for him to get in that cage get caged
right now okay man got she beat let's go exercise that motherfucker
that is why you also want to get off gandalf when that happens
fun fact throughout all the films are going were born mere spraysters through them yeah his costume
gets like um oh yeah there's there's hidden purple studs in those rooms the enemies come out
this is the first time we've had true adventurer as well we're in the second game and it's the
first time it's happened right wallop him he'll do the run around then you need to come gandalf
if gandalf would like to stay alive and then fuck you and then exercise the shit out him
and then now he's healthy again we did it i'm gonna need you to suck the saruman out oh no
strongy help me sermons taking over my tentacle help help oh no i'm gonna do what we're gonna do
he would have lost if it was fun
when patreon oh you want that plot in patreon that's which and no i'm not putting lord of the rings
fucking inspired audio i mean i could i'd rather watch the version of the asus
i call upon the men of rohan open war is upon you i know what it is you want on me
but i will not bring further death to my people
hmm
he like literally what the fuck bro we just saved you and you're saying
your girlfriend leads me to lord of the rings by the fire honestly i don't know if i have
the lungs for that and i can't read properly as well i don't know maybe i could do it i wouldn't
actually mind that and then i'll timestamp it so you've got all the chapters then we can read it
together for the first time because then i'll literally be like oh i didn't know that i didn't
literally every page is me going i didn't know that oh my god that's so cool oh so that's how
they did it in the movie but they got it from the suite and because apparently ganda oh sorry
let me on the horse um apparently gandalf was like constantly looking at the actual book for
reference um you want to go lego last for this one because he can snipe the enemies off the horses
wherever the enemies are once they spawn it again um like you don't you can get do you oh okay i guess
i just don't okay no it's fine i just want you to hurt the enemies no he just you're are you okay
legolas legolas legolas can you aim mother legolas hello okay one you suck two i'm going on freaking
aragon what was that where's the enemy you you're first right no you're first okay there we go okay
we're just sticking with aragon because i don't know why legolas doesn't have aimbot right now
maybe uh maybe next uh because we've had the instance open for quite a while we may be running
into a few little buggy wuggies but it's okay let's just try our best try our best with what we
got i saw that enemy get back here you be funny i know i've got you talking
um obviously there's a lot to do in this area um no one is contesting lord of the ring ASMR
be wrong it sounds weird i mean the books are double yeah but if i read the books for the first
time i'd constantly be i've got yoy put me down geez um i'd constantly be like oh that's so cool
how they did this i ain't ready like i know about the characters like tom bombadil and all that
and like i understand why they made a few choices not to put certain stuff in like obviously tom
bombadil is just too to put in the movie so i literally just saw you yeah freaking get back
here why are you running halfway across the map hypnotizing you to read the
mean not suck
you're
the little lego break apart then
it's one of the points in my to-do list i know but it's definitely something i'll do the end so
i don't plan on doing it anytime soon
get a load of this oh brother this guy thanks
well we're unlocking more people as well we now have gandalf way we can buy more characters on the
pod and the map which is good
and we made it this time
with only 30 000 studs but we're almost half a millionaire maybe we're quarter of a millionaire
but we're not half of them and we get too miss real for doing that one oh we're just two we're
actually just anything i forgot how many playable characters are in the game yes they also do a few
outfit one which i think is cheesy do the one if the outfit doesn't bring anything different
right we're about to do helm speak
who's ready for helm seed we have to protect our people of rohan and the orcs are coming at
night we ought to try our best to defend and then something happened in the middle of the night
i can't quite remember then we won the battle battle of helm steve we won it easy peasy peasy
battle of helmsd so few of you have returned
and similarly i remember my dad had me sit down and watch the whole trilogy when i was alive
but i fell asleep so quickly and everything fell so they think are gone perish they have no idea
oh well there you go they really cut down this plot real quick he already back
all eyes and god is indeed how many and right to ruin 10 000 you make a parody now it is an army
bred for a single vote to destroy the world of men let them come i want every man i want to be their
arms it's too easy get the women and children into the cave you'll get your time don't worry you'll
get you'll get your arc we promise and then the behind the scenes are just like is it myory
people myory because they're like so big naturally they all became ira kai like in the behind the
scenes and all the female horse riders sorry all the horse riders in the movies were actually female
because they're lighter for the horses to carry all the accessories and stuff as well
oh my god the elves are actually helping not lifelong you know differences being cast aside
defeat the same enemy i love it i love it i love when when feuds get buried under to defeat a big
i'm an absolute select for a plot like that i'm sorry it's just the best thing ever it's like
when two enemies have to come together to defeat an evil or boss um that's why john wick failed so
badly um he had a great time listening to the stream i work but i must go away and your episodes
of dnd dropped have fun listening
okay what's going on i have a crank i have a gemily i have a lego last to shoot stuff okay let's go
lego last to shoot that target so i can see it okay you know what i'll go f myself then for even
thinking i stood a chance truly
any of you's getting hungy should we get a quick break
actually how many more levels do i have to go
i might be a cheeky sod and ask for a refuel and get some chicken pie in the
oh i need gimme up here what is going on i don't know why you only keep
that rather strange i just made a bit more tea right now okay we're all think we're on the same wavelength
nutrition time thank you tiny spany for the super chat i am not here today i'm doing absolutely
terrible so i like to do like the unwritten rule of being a streamer which is literally
safe people saying as they do i don't know why i'm struggling too much today i'm having a stroke
what do you mean only having four hours is like is unacceptable okay throw him up as well i guess
you're slightly less than halfway through we're doing it i'll give you a different type of pie how
dare you forever strong you should rest i literally took my sleep medication yesterday
and i had a nap and i'm like the body just give me eight hours i'm so exhausted
but i can't use the sleep medicine anymore for a while because it's not like you can't rely on it
and so i'm a bit up shit creek for the next few days if i don't naturally go to sleep
and so it is what do you do
i mean i'll sleep well after you know we do a year of streaming
i'll sleep i'll sleep well when i get my first stream break i bet you i'll be so used to waking
up that i actually can't enjoy the day off and end up just coming back on the phone i'll end up
doing a pop-up stream because i'd be like it's so weird not streaming every single day um i'm very
excited because i get to put my montage together um of my uh month two of streams um we get to put
that together and then i get to have this fun we're scambling when you need them you shouldn't
rely on it in the first place it's just uh there's just so my body keeps trying to enter a deep
sleep right before stream and i'm trying to artificially pull it back a couple hours and it's
just failing like i got six i got seven hours of sleep the other day i was fucking over that moon
like sorry i had that base i don't i can't remember what day it was honestly the days are
starting to blend together blend to get a
no worries don't worry be happy like as i said i get really fun stream
whoa not like that hold on a minute hold on a minute we're on the blue side yeah um i do get like
i just don't feel stressed and i have a good time but as soon as i hit that end broadcast
oh i'm really just not perished it bro i need to throw gimley please stop
i just got an achievement finish one of gimley's opponents for him
and then okay that was actually a good achievement name i'll give him that
and then gimley you're the last one here and we did damn right you did you could do it in secret
i don't know i feel like it'd be obvious because i'd just stop talking everyone'd be like that
strange this one he's not talking anymore this is all you can conjure saruman oh don't say that you
just jinxed it it's berserker he's mental
illiterately he's mental oh wait no that can't be berserker doesn't this guy blow himself up
i can't remember
oh
legolas having one job i mean he tanked the arrow wait what can we do if we tank the arrow
get your man over there
are we right you're not flying on a shield like a kite young man stop though
uh right what do i need to do here
is there a secret behind this wall or is this another mission yeah okay sorry there's another
mission where there's a secret behind the wall uh i have no idea what i'm supposed to do
where's gimley oh you're literally i couldn't even see him i assume this is you
something something and by axe true and real true and
and then legolas jumped up the shield the skateboards actually it's a surfboard moment
all over again what or who is this is that legolas moment
and then push this and then they can all jump up and then
gimley will smash the stone and then we'll progress to the next section because
they actually put it in game that y'all have to toss me oh it's not here sorry it's the next bit
they actually put it in game are you ready are you ready are you ready
adrenaline is pumping
i can hit petal falling from a tree for 300 paces all those so legolas i cannot hit an
point blank no one in his way because my bow's a little bit slippery
shiver me timber
it's a long way
okay there is a wee thing down here you can grab without having to do anything in particular
and but there's a golem wall there obviously we don't have them unlocked but ready
me
then we beat them up beat them up beat them up beat them up shoot them up shoot them up
make them regret it make it hurt make it hurt baby make it hurt
make them regret spawning make them regret spawning yes my house
my rules okay we're gonna patch up the door real quick you know the one any the one any intruders
they made indiana jones lego they did
i played the first one because my dad got me it because he knew i like lego star wars
but the only reason i like lego star wars is because i like lego star wars you know what i mean
like that's why i like it so much and like the reason i like lego lord is it rings so much and
i don't need i need some tails put on the floor where do they come from
where did they go where did they come from cotton i don't know where the things come from
oh it's by the ladders sorry it's really obvious it's the ladders
and i miss every single shot because that's why we might hold on let me aim for him goodbye
thank you and then there's gonna be a new one that pops up so we're just gonna aim
boom
will be another one
i like the service too when i was a little bit
they made a pirate so early they did a harry potter now i'd like the harry potter if it was
all one continuation but it's not as split into two games and i can't be arsed with that
although i actually wanted to give that like oh no it's not like the harry potter game a shot
it got rated so highly and i've still not played it i've not seen any footage or gameplay but it
got rated really highly and i don't know if it's a good game or if it's just the game that got
rated highly because it's harry potter because it's like a loved franchise type thing
these are the questions i have if i will know the truth to soon tm
um what's why
oh i'm to do something down here hold on i'm to build something oh platform to get them up okay i
understand um harry potter one to four is decent five to seven is pretty near
um
he's only twitching because my axis is fine
you can build an rtd to joy and not get crushed by a rock and give your reward i
don't even recall that i've never hundred percent in star wars before but i want to do that i was
going to do it on me for the fortress is taken that's quite a while away to plan a stream it is over
what can men do against such reckless hate why did my track and get lost i'm literally staring
at my right out why did you do that don't do that again i'm going to recalibrate
yes let this be the hour when we draw swords together oh he changed his mind
oh
oh no oh no i've forgotten okay we need to jump at the doorway we're just going to spam jump okay
we have to jump in the doorway or we are going to horrifically mess this up do you understand
jump motherfucker jump no i jumped too early but i knew what i had to do i knew what i had to do
no okay there's three boxes up ahead if i'm not or it may be the next one
come on oh please let me do this thing right away oh my god it's the same i need oh my god i
can't believe i did that what a twat back honestly okay i need the same i need the same
okay we at least got that one i cannot believe i did that i knew it was there
check back and i'll see the lego ass the recent higher part of the game is excellent if you want
to explore hog what not a lot you don't gift it i'll literally knew it was there that's the one i
and gandalf's back in the roster down the hill they go
and they literally cannot see me when i go outside what's going on here you can ride it
on god on horseback and get the get it back honestly i messed up the run sequence on
proto at the start it's the right side i messed it up there and the next one the next level
also has one like that and there's also one on she loves to lair and i just know i'm going to twat it
up new characters available to buy
okay we're almost at 400 000 studs as long as we have enough to buy berserker it's fine
i can't remember where the times two stud stuff is but once you get like times a billion stud
it's fine we will wipe your will we get foods or will we play one more and then get food i don't know
okay saruman's saruman i has moved away to the black gate now so uh frodo and that can't do anything
so we can't progress here we have to go back to salmon frodo this is like how deeply they thought
about this game they were like you can't progress type thing so it's really smart i think it was smart
anyway so we're about to get kidnapped by we're who the fuck when did you join the team okay we're
with borrow mirrors and brother soramir i'm just i don't actually don't know is then saruman
this is the last level of two towers okay we'll send it and then we'll get some food to refuel
and then i saw that teleport and then we will do the last movie literally that guy's asking for
help ignore him he doesn't we we don't have the things he desires okay i relate my fire we have
not what he desires fire amir the disappoint no i was kind of even on the same with that but i guess not
he is the crispy brother i've never just i wouldn't say i would i've ever described
or heard someone describe a sibling they're crispy get food i'll get food after this one
and then i'ma go numb numb numb numb numb numb
i hope you're taken to east and shore they're no much too great by nightfall we'll be over at
it's calling to himself rodo's not doing well the ring starting to take a good grip on photo the
poor guy you need to know what happened to boromir oh we about to get the lore the ring drove your
brother mad oh he criss because he got fired by that oh i understand that reference now
i understand that reference now i get it sad energy what do you think of the voice
lego games part of the tour my lego star wars is how they convey the story i like if they lift it
directly from the movie i am fine if it's lifted directly from the movie or if it's not voice acted
at all um i um enjoy it because um out with a sentence from us jesus uh i enjoy it because yeah as
you say that did not just happen um wait what was the sentence yes i like it when they do it if
they actually get voice actors in that aren't the voice actors i find it a bit like not jarring
not like the makes the game bad but i'm just like like okay i got it out i've got it out it's out
okay i've got my sentence out too busy look sorry i the the kind of focus the dedication it takes
to literally move a little bit in a lego game shopping um yes i don't did the new ones end up
getting things
it's like someone doing an abridged series more or less of the voices
and like yeah i'm gonna pop this then we're gonna tell professor sorry my brain's short i need to
eat i need to eat i'm sorry i'm hungry i'm hungry i need to refuel my brain so i can keep talking
because because it's starting to go and i'm tired being because i did tours of talking in the
meeting well i didn't think i actually did and so i need to refuel my brain oh my god is that
cotton bum in the harem what were you giffy gubbers up to the member stream i remember you were
doing a member stream weren't you right how do i get what how did i get oh it was that simple it
was that simple how is the membership stream go cake rate uh oh did you do a baking you did one
month anniversary of membership you did baking did it work did you actually put it in the oven i
know that sounds silly but like did you put it in the oven and stuff and it came out or was it like
did it not come out right at all i'll take your word for it here i'm it came out you did it all
that's fantastic oh my god okay young it tasted great oh that's delicious was fia there did you
get to see fia i loved fia cam yesterday on the uh the heart rate monitor stream fia cam was so cute
cake rate she put it in the oven all right the cake the um wait oh i need him to shoot the thing uh
we little reeflings and strong zoe are um i will post to africa oh my god please tweet it i want to
see it and the reeflings and i are up to shenanigans and lego lord of the rings um i'm praising how
fantastic the game is and how it's the best game ever and if it's something you think you'd like
i heavily recommend it because it's a fun lot game um we're doing 100 completion today um
and yeah we are just in the campaign mode at the moment and i feel like lord of the rings this
might be the game for you uh or i feel like lego games highly recommend it very well polished
she said as a i was praising how polished the game was and then um something may or may not
happened where the game almost froze on me hehehe but for the most part it's pretty dang polished
okay all the lego games are peaked even the arkham one i never played the batman one
um i think mommy is gonna like the performance of that member what does that mean that is so
arbitrary what am i supposed to take from that okay we need to go back to faramir the most ignored
child yes you'll see okay okay shivi got over a thousand and stuff for her medical bills oh that's
so lovely thank you here um i'm sure that brings a lot of stress relief for shivi as well so thank
you on behalf of shivi i'm sure she completely um i'm sure she already made it very clear how grateful
she is and all that does but as well as an extension because we love shadow wizard money gang we love
neggos in this house we love cats they're precious little things um not cake but actual cake i can't
believe it the lude vtuber agency is talking about an actual cake and not the cake via the slang term
for a gluteus maximus watch the heck shivi you're getting suspended for seven days for not making
enough of the child could you imagine them could you imagine them right sam get going that plan
yeah i was trying not to cry looky so that's so precious bless your car honestly make sure you
get a good relaxing after that stream lacks no cool shouldn't some people outside of the school
when a couple of guys who were up to no good started making trouble in your neighborhood
they got into one oh banshee i know it's not called a banshee okay just let me let me call it banshee
madam we cry for you
see i hope the girls would be able to get what me and the reeflings have i think i can confidently
say that haram and sheebie have what uh you and i have what a reefling i think that's very fair to say
which is very sweet it makes me a very happy bean to think like that
right golem has a secret ability of being able to fish believe it or not well actually no that is
believable because he's literally yes it makes me so happy it's all everyone is oh that's so cute
thank you for bringing the girls this movie we love them and we love you all all the love all the
foot we'll reveal our unity let's go i love my horse in brackets affectionately you mean being
codependent on each other well definitely for me and the reeflings i don't know i don't know i don't
know i don't know but look all i'm saying is i may or may not be getting a nicotine patch upgrade as
well shortly and then i'll put i have a little toggle and then you'll be able to see my little
nicotine patch as well okay bye yeah oh look ccc there is this is the one that's behind the
dang wall how are you supposed to see this when you're so focused on the dang dragon
not tell you how many times that's called me out affectionate i'm dependent on boomy we love her
could have been reason we don't need to tell you this but i'll say it anyway take good care of
thank you again for the redirect she be and embers as well for that matter
and anyone who you'd like to like don't worry understand that like the lord of the rings
might not be for you or i might not be the streamer for you don't worry don't feel bad
something like oh i feel so bad if i don't like hang around and stuff and it's like bro i assure
you i completely and wholeheartedly comprehend that i am not the streamer for everyone like i'm
literally going apeshit over this game because i love it so much and it's like yeah don't don't
we're gonna go grab this money here though
i would i would wonder how many did a hundred percent complete this game
what i think that's what you asked me i saw functioning when strone is right here oh come on
it oh no he saw it he saw it i'm in trouble hold on i messed up i went a little too far with
rhodo oh don't glitch out now don't glitch out now don't glitch out now i'll i will cry if this
game glitches out it's well polished though but don't glitch out though that completely missed
the marker that's all i'm gonna say she has a wizarding way i've never seen that one i've played
this game like three five six is it nicotine or strontine or strontium yeah maybe we should
say it's not a nicotine the lower behind the the concept artist gave me and i was like yeah this
looks perfect um oh you can hear the music it fills me with so much happiness here
it hit a more sensitive area listen it's gimley
what
oh i love that sentence a wizard should no better should no better what the heck
oh i'm getting i'm getting tingly goosebumps i fucking love the end fate i love it so much
i love it so much i love this fucking part so much it's so fucking juicy right i don't normally
i was like i'm not gonna do this this this but um these ones i'm gonna do because i'll end up
forgetting when we do the playthrough over so i'm gonna like grab this stuff and do it right
we need to destroy the water aqueducts okay so ignore everything else i think it says water
aqueduct is one of five one of five oh my god you're such an MLG gamer like imagine having
the brain capacity to even know it was that one come on so there's also three markings on the tower
as well which we need to destroy they're taking the hobbits to isengard actually the i the the
hobbits are taking over isengard they ain't taken you know they the the hobbits the hobbits the hobbits
the hobbits to isengard the hobbits the hobbits the hobbits isengard
no we are actually supposed to hit that i don't know if we can hit it from here though
no we're out of range okay if you get too close to the edge um it is a bit too hot for the end
so we're just gonna drop that it's not a big deal we're gonna break this bridge oh nice we can pick
it up again i ain't gonna complain we're taking the hobbits to isengard
break the release the river literally it's okay right we're gonna do the tower one oh i need to
go back and do that fire one there i've just spotted it sorry i can't believe it i'm not
doing the most efficient speed round of this game when you said someone did it in eight hours
ridiculous right there we go that's two of three on the tower we're gonna unfortunately go back
you need to put that water tower on the fire there's three of them on this map as well
and just give me a second you know i'm quite big as an ant as an ant
aim see him i love the song where you get the mithril fire on the oh it's so cute there's like
the all the please excuse me i'm literally getting stuck in the game um there's a lot of cute items
that not all the mithril items that we smith at the black smith will have like a super like
important purpose one of three oh there oh no it's not there's just straight up a treasure under it
so this should be three of no this is a water wheel oh it is a water wheel hold on i'm just
analyzing the map i see one all the way over there to the left which we will investigate
i think that's everything in this area we are getting a nice chunk of change though
i don't think we need to be worried about funds thankfully like when you buy the
tames to stud like the red brick and all that i think we're gonna be doing all right
we're gonna be doing all right um
uh halfway there saruman the way more like saruman the stinky oh it's such a good meme
it's a perfect meme it's such a good meme
right okay let's see we'll go this water one here we're gonna destroy the tower
that's four or five i'll do the tower one next sorry it takes so long to move around
just the end this map is massive and all the wee little things you have to do
if you want to like do it right the first time it's a bit pernicating there's the wee
wee bits and bobs to do saruman the way is more like saruman the finding out
fucking me i'm on fire now
so there we go i guess added automatically it's not like we're gonna reach out and
grab it we're gonna get this water you guys are asking me if i'm turning australian i'm getting
this water yeah just need to get this water and then destroy the bridge yeah then mate right
we're gonna go a little to the left mate not that not the hit video game a little to the left
the new dlc that came up then we're gonna finish off what we need to do over here why is there
floating enemies on the bridge i think that they were on the bridge before i destroy no they are
floating about they're getting stuck on stuff okay it should be a treasure right here
so then this is the last kind of water wheel type mechanic i think we're doing
perfect and then there's one more
okay now looks can be this evening okay look a little to the right
you're in the main shaft looking for diamonds i okay if i can hit it okay there is something
here to hit shit i think i have to go around a bit at the top there's a main shaft is i gonna hit it
okay there we go and it's you can't you will not pick this up because obviously
you'll be focused on the main objective it's like one of those things i'm so happy you're
playing the lego game like we're here for the nostalgia they didn't make me do it three times
blasphemous behavior blasphemous behavior we didn't do it three times not a real video game
what's oh what oh i'm stuck on something and the camera is not helping either
absolute blasphem what are you supposed to find in the main part without knowing about let it some
of this stuff is so hidden like you have to look it up there's no way i refuse i refuse
how am i supposed to know right we're gonna literally be oh no i think we have to interact
we do okay let's go beat the damn thing oh i didn't know if it was a freaking b button
quite all right i wasn't spamming b i didn't know it was a b thing hold on
okay we did it uh break them up and down
so
just him green
bye beeflings don't worry if you have to go and get stuff done i understand
ha
hope you have to dig it evening good night mama
welcome my lord to eisen god
under your god there's no power anymore
he's a prisoner of eisen god
did the tree just go surf away they love surfing in this game it's so cute
mashing her button live right now
bonk i'm not i'm not sure he's reaching the head over hand over
really
pippin you fool batuk he can he help himself honestly he's actually he can he help himself
he means well he just gets curious you're looking
golem is finally unlocked so we can claim walls in the free world if we so desire we are unlocking
unlocking more characters to buy in the free world um that's why that's one way to hide an orb
like the reason why we're playing chess isn't i'm gonna cheat in chess that's all i'm saying for
that stream we're cheating in chess or i'm cheating in chess you might not be bad well you know i'm playing
69 percent i know this is the most um mini kits i've ever gotten
jay do you not get the reference
how do you cheat in chess wait you guys don't know the story
in chess chess accused the guy of cheating but no one figured out how he cheated so then the
internet went wild and then said oh he shoved up and he was getting vibrations mid-match and like
everyone ran with it and it was so silly
and good news pippin knows nothing real answer
don't worry about that yeah you forgot that was the funniest thing ever
so we're gonna go to the secret stairs with golem sam in total
all right golem
come on now what's what wells to go
follow me follow me oh follow me when's that song
don't
okay i'm going to call a food break i will be literally like two minutes i'm going to beat the
fuck out of this chicken pie in the microwave i'm gonna eat that thing in give a little two minutes
well two minutes 30 maybe get a grab a little egg on the side i'm gonna get another bottle of
water because i am sweating i am wearing my black undies from yesterday and the sweat around
the thigh area i don't know why this game is so intense for me i think because i'm just so madly
in love with it but there's something wrong with me from how for how excited i am to play a lego
game the the amount of sweat that is on my persons right now is not making sense it's not adding up
i need to calm down okay literally high octane gaming um i'm actually doing it
okay i heavily recommend to all of you please get up have a little stretch grab some food if you
can or a snack if you so desire if you've not eaten already um and if you're not interested in
eating and it might be your bedtime soon you can quickly brush your teeth and then come back and
i'll ramble you to sleep or some plain more she'd be posted a picture of the cake okay i'll
pull it up i'll pull up you don't just eat your chicken patty no golly i thought she was cheating
in chess because she can move freely in chess but i look like kitchen tiles you can't say that no
wrestling that's funny but don't say that i lied okay i'm going to very quickly start the story
mode oh 60.1 percent um i just ate you had a burger you didn't let me have a bite
math 1618 thank you for the 10 gifted membership congrats to those lurking who caught it with your
face um i think golem needs to come up here oh that's literally why we unlock golem because
we're doing the secret stairs okay i'm going to very quickly uh let you enjoy the the campaign
i'm gonna heat up my food okay i'll be right back
what
so
So, I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit
Stop throwing up, it's fine. I had to go and get some food. Stop. That's funny as
fuck. Stop throwing up, you're fine. It was three minutes, literally it was two minutes
thirty for me to put it in the microwave. Okay, it's okay, do these throw up. I put
Zaro Dumzi Dan. Okay, let's see, let's see. Right, we are on the map called the Secret
Stairs. Gollum is luring us to Shilob on purpose. Shilob, if you do not take control of Frodo
he will walk to that fucking gate. I'll just let him, we only need him for a few sections
and he's about to walk past the section, we actually need him back. But yes, Gollum is
trying to be naughty naughty and get rid of us because he himself doesn't have the physical
strength to overpower the two of us, he is emaciated if you didn't know. He definitely,
where the fuck is he? Stop it, stop it. Yeah, this is getting out of hand. I for thank you
for cleaning up after the reflins. Look, they don't know what they mean, okay, they just thought
very well. But yes, the Gollum is aware that he just can't get rid of us, so he's going
to use Shilob to do it. Where are these bump into? And as I said, we've now entered the
third movie, so we are actually about to wrap up this section of the game. The world. Where did
that go? Every least Legos that we can build. We're going to do that, we're going to grab a
hold of Frodo because he cannot stop walking onto that mountain. Fine. And then what happens after
that? I don't know. I'm trying to remember the sequence of how the section goes, but I can't.
We've unlocked the staircase. Oh, maybe one part of the staircase. Well, it will only take me three
hours to get to the third movie. So what, an hour and a half for like the campaign mode of the movie?
I think so. We just need to unlock the bottom step. But yeah, Gollum is a mischievous. So
Smeagol is the good side of Gollum. So when he's all nice and, oh, I would never do that,
that's what's talking to Smeagol. But when the ring takes over, he becomes Gollum because Gollum
is actually a hobbit. But the ring, over 500 years, warped him, transformed him.
It's just a chicken pie. It's a chicken pie with vegetables, chicken, some sort of creamy
sauce in it. An egg that I boiled and lots of green vegetables. I wasn't kidding when I said
I'm looking after my health. I'm trying to be dead. I'll munch through this. Yeah, got my egg as well.
Love me protein. Love me eggs. I wish I could eat red meat more, but I just don't like the taste of
it that much. Like I do have a steak, but
Sheila can be a very sexy woman in Shadow of War.
I have a plan for next week, but I'm a bit worried about it.
We even jumped that. I feel like we're so tiny as wee hobbits is.
Oh, it's a very far full.
I'm going to try and eat this while I play. So if I choke, it's been nice knowing you.
Okay, eggs are really dry to eat.
That boiled egg. God damn, why is this so dry inside?
As if I didn't mash it up and like pop it and boil it more.
Choking is a little, unless it's, yeah, yeah, I was going to say it. I was going to say it,
but then, but then you may as well just finish it because you started it. You were thinking it.
You said it. Oh, we should watch White Chicks soon.
The game, see, when the game does that, I'm ready to fire on it. Don't be so rude.
You knew exactly what I was trying to achieve.
Exactly what I was trying to achieve. I haven't seen the movie in so long.
It's so ridiculous.
Oh, that's the Sam thing.
Sam McGee. What the fuck is his name? Sam? Why is Gamgee? Jesus.
Why do I think his name is Sam McGee?
That's it. Everyone's come to Scottish right now.
I'm going to amighe this and amighe that.
Okay, trying to eat and play at the same time is truly impossible by all accords.
I say it happens. There's no way I can eat and play at the same time. Gollum, we need you.
Okay, thank you, Gollum.
Gollum, what do you think about the chicken pie?
Well, it's not fish, is it?
Okay, now I'm coughing up the egg. Let's not do that.
As fun as that little gag is, let's not do that. Okay, my voice has had enough for one day.
Where is the item? Oh, there it is. Oh, it's a build thing.
Would ASMR a patreon pair session?
No, gagging's fine. Like, actual choking and asphyxiation is a no-no.
Oh, wait, this is a Sam thing, damn it.
Dagnabbit, Sam's supposed to go up here. Right, beat up the little fishpile.
Beat it up. Show it to his boss. Right, where's Sam? Sam?
To the one refling that's called Sam. You're so welcome to token. You're so welcome.
All I'm doing is saying your name. I don't know if any refling would actually be called Frodo.
Gonna be honest, that might be a bit of a stretch.
You got Haggis cooking shrimp? I've never prepared Haggis in my life.
There's no chance of it happening. I wish I was a Sam, real. I'm jealous.
That's it, I'm doing it. I'm opening up the top 10 boy names.
Uh, Jack, John, Alex, Sam, I guess, technically.
What are other boy names?
Justin? I can't think of 80 guy names. Why is it when you want to think of something,
your brain's like, I got nothing.
I could carry it for a while.
And now the rings making Frodo think that Sam is a platinum.
James, yeah, James as well. All of J's. J's are really so popular with the pop.
Joe, Joseph, is that gonna sell?
Can someone post the top 10 popularity?
Oh my god, you tried Scottish tablet?
Matt, oh my god, Scottish tablet. It's delicious. I remember the first time I ate it.
I eat it by scraping it along my teeth like a weirdo because it's so satisfying.
Mike, yeah, definitely top 10 stuff. Can I think of like older guy names?
Okay, so now it's just me and Gollum, but Gollums are naughty, naughty boy.
You're such a naughty boy. So if we go top left, it should be the design for this level up here,
the little meat rail. Oh yeah, there it is. You can just beat up this web. At first you
might think you can't beat past it. No, but you can beat up. Do you like tablet or fudge more?
Definitely tablet. It would be tablet, then caramel, and then fudge. I'm not the biggest fudge fan.
Oh, wait, hold on. I'm gonna eat him and move him in game and I'm like, this isn't gonna go well.
There's gonna be like some special event I need to. But I don't want my fruit to get cold.
I got free money. Gee, sounds like all money. Is there something over here?
Nope. No, these are just little decorations. Oh, gee, I wonder if there's a bit of treasure
behind that. Gee will occurs, it would be sure would be.
Escaped tablet with my teeth. I don't know why I eat it like that, but it's just the best way to eat it.
Mmm, Scottish fudge is completely different, I'd believe it. There's this TikToker from the
Shetland Islands, and she runs like a bakery type thing, then they do deliveries depending on where
you are. And she's like super fucking popular for all the stuff they can ship. Like if you can ship it
in the UK, then you can pretty much do it. I'm trying to eat so fast I can't do it.
Hot chocolate fudge cake with ice creams?
That's like apple pie and ice cream and stuff, hell yeah.
No way they put a jumpscare in a child's game. The poor children that play this game
must have shot their pantylons at that. Oh, like there's she love in the background.
No, you get back here, she love. You get back here, or else I'm going to beat you up.
Tablet is just a bar of sugar. Just type in Scottish tablet, it really is just a bar of sugar,
but it's really bad. What is it? What are you doing, photo? Just take out the flail, okay? Just take
out. If you're going to be mugged about it, we'll hold this.
Um, so I can't commentate, eat and think about the gameplay at the same time. I need to pick one.
I'm eating, I'm hungry, okay? Come on, let me eat me. Let me eat, put me in coach. Wait,
why did you beat that up? Oh, no, no, no, don't hurt Gollum yet, he hasn't turned.
I just eat. Oh my god, I can't believe you all make fun of me for being an architect, bro,
and then you go down to me. Oh my god, that's it, I'm on to you refunds. I'm actually on to you.
I see how you, I see how you make fun of me. Oh, and then, and then when I do it, when you do it,
it's fine. No, I'm on to you. Rules for thee, but not for me. Aye, I see it.
I'm eating. Oh shit, is it left or right left? Is this the one? No, it was right up. Yes, it was right.
Okay, okay. Okay, right side. Okay, I'm fine, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm right,
right, left, right, I'm fine.
Yeah, we messed up, but we know.
He's always right. Literally, the developers love the right side of the game.
The hands on the face.
Shield for Jamfro. Yeah, mm-hmm. I'm on board with absolutely all suggestions, even slime. I will
forgive you for slimes. Something tells me that's not the end of them.
It's you. I'm on your side. I know.
So sorry, Sam. So sorry.
They're so, so sorry.
22.0 for Jamfro. Fuck it.
Fuck it. Anything you want to get. That map was called Not a Little Fly. Sorry,
that achievement was called Not a Little Fly. That's very cute. Sam, the greatest of all time.
No, she loved, she loved father. He was bigger than I'm in.
I ring VTuber for Jamfro. Jamfro is going to be very curious.
Do we have a Zebra? I remember someone asked for a Zebra for Jamfro. I'm like, right here.
Mm-hmm. Sam really is the greatest of all time in their trilogy.
A hero always needs the helping hand type thing or else,
or else, you know, the hero can't do his thing like a support fan. I remember reading
something or I consumed some sort of video and it was like, why is Sam so important? And it was
more, it was deeper than just like egg V. He's like doing all this stuff. It was like every,
you know, token did it on purpose because Samwise name means like,
oh, I can't remember any of the video about consumed it. That's good enough. That's good enough.
You know what? I did my part. I'm going to burp. I'm so sorry. Oh, that was pathetic burp.
That's all you can muster. He'll wimp. That's the best burp you can muster. Disgusting.
Oh, the ice stabbed out. Notice that?
Mm-hmm. Mummy's losing her burps, honestly.
God, Frodo cannot catch her, but that's the third time this poor gentleman is being stabbed on
his adventure. Whenever someone's like, oh, as much as I wanted Frodo to stay in the shire,
that poor boy, he was so young to go through all of that.
Um, I can't remember the sequence.
Honestly, I say that every time we enter a new level. I'm like, oh, I can't remember the sequence.
I can't remember the sequence. And then I immediately remember what I need to do.
So we need to scare Sheila into, oh, no, oh, well, no, oh, well, I've done it now.
I've just dropped both items. Oh, I completely balls that one off. I'm going to be honest,
balls that one off. Actually, good. Let's try that again. So Sheila will be scared.
Yes, question mark.
I don't know what happened there, but yeah, I think we're okay.
I don't know. I don't know.
She ground pound and she read it. Did any help come off of her? I don't know if any help.
Oh, no, we bugging out. I don't know. I'm going to swap to the other guy. I don't know if she's
taking health damage or not. I'm just spamming the controller. I can't see what we're supposed to do.
Hi, hi. Thank you for joining me. We'll do it one more time on Sam, which is fine.
One more time. If it doesn't work, we might have to close and open.
As I said, the longer the game runs, the more buggy. Oh, well, okay.
Is this what we were supposed to be seeing? Oh, my God. Oh, we did it. Okay, okay, I counted.
The big red hitbox. Don't miss it.
Back you, she demon. Why the spider kind of bad? Don't know.
Please do not hurt the spider. That was a red one. Yeah, because there's a bug on the screen
and it's bugging out. Hold on, wait. Oh, that was so funny when there was a bug on screen
and there was bugging out. All right, all right, all right. Wrap it up. Wrap it up.
I don't think they want to hurt the spider. No, I don't think they want to hurt it either.
That shiny shirt. That's mine.
Wasn't Sam the only mortal to win Sheila? Oh, I didn't know that.
I finished my food. I'm all healthy and refueled.
I'm gonna get this done. They took the ring. No, they didn't.
I beg your pardon, Franklin, but you are mistaken in the good way.
See, he feels relief holding up. Not like, ah, shit, I'm back on the...
Oh, my God, he's got his legs are quivering. That's why I want to see you like when I'm finished
with you. Look at that quivering with anticipation. Oh, Stroney, what are you gonna do next to me?
I don't know. I've not decided yet. Please, I'll do anything. Yes, exactly. You will do anything
for me. That's why you will submit. Okay, what does that do?
Oh, I see it. Bunk.
Muscle spasms over over taxation. I've seen those ones where like people come out
of their gym and their legs like having the biggest like muscle spasm to mankind.
Ooh, we got a cog.
Why? We can't reach that because we're not an elf. See, I told you this game has issues.
This game's indeed real. Mimmy ink. Mommy drops a chandelier on you, ASMR, win.
The amount of memes, I might start putting like ASMR memes on Twitter when it's like a little thingy.
Maybe I'll make ASMR memes sure it's like like a really silly thing but I can't turn it into
like a full-blown role-player or anything like that. That would be quick.
Right, they're breaking down the door. They're breaking down the door. Oh wait, you can just
skip these guys. Yeah, I remembered. You could just skip it. We do even need to fight them.
I love when games do that where they put in like secret things. You can skip and you
love to everything about it again. Have you seen when it's a mouse crawling under this kit?
Wait, what? Like in the mummy with a scarab? Okay, we're not allowed to get past the gate
without looking like an orc, okay? We need to look like an orc or else we're not getting anywhere.
So, we're gonna bonk this pipe and then we're gonna get an armor piece for him and then Sam's
gonna be covered and he farts at me. That was loud enough to be picked up on make. I just want you
guys to know that if I didn't mute you literally would have heard that. So, Sam now has a chest
plate. We just need a helm for Sam and we are gonna avoid them because I don't want to get into
trouble. I don't even know where you came from. You had muscle cramps so bad. You need to have
bananas are good for you. Where or where? I'm supposed to burn this I guess and then you jump on
that. We're burning this whole fortress to the ground. Oh yeah, it's like the high table.
We're gonna catapult ourselves up.
Certainly looks like it. I don't know what it looks like for you, chief. It certainly looks like it to
be. It's really magnesium. I have been lied to. I've been misled. I can't believe it. I've been
deceived. What's got magnesium in it? I don't even know. Name one magnesium food source right now.
You can't eat that. All right, I think Frodo. Oh no, I need Frodo to come up here.
What's this? A helmet? Sure. I'll put a stick on Frodo. Magnesium supplements. Milk or magnesium?
I've got some reeflings that are deficit and have a deficit in magnesium.
Okay, so what you need to do and it took me forever to find this one. You need to go invisible so he
doesn't close the damn gate. Okay. Spinach? Spinach. Potassium, magnesium, sodium are all
fishies. I don't eat much fish. I should eat fish. I should make an effort to eat more fish.
So you need to go secret mode and then climb up here and then you done.
Grab that. Break this apart. Nope, other side I guess. Break this apart and then get the handle
and then you can Hulk smash down the Gimli-style wire and then beat the crap out of the guy at the
door because he's annoying and he stinks. Oh brother. And then give Sam the helmet and then
we'll take Frodo to do the chest plate up ahead. Oh no, we need Sam again. We need Sam to burn
the fire this way. There's a fish monger near me and I never know what to order because I ordered
shit. Oh no, I was doing so well. I was doing so well not to say that for so long. Just goes to
show you can you have it all, can you? Not you, can you? No you can't. Well if you're going to be on
the floor, how about you stay there? Oh that's fine. You stay there and get the rest of them.
She can't help it. I still haven't downloaded it literally to show it at the start of stream
because it's just a redonkulousness. Does that give me? Oh it doesn't give me adventure. Jeez.
And when we can't stop the Rebecca's takeaway, we can take that one as well.
Everyone has their downsides. Like no one can be perfect and mine's clearly fucking brain-wrong.
Hi hi, please let us through. We're just two little orcs. We're just really malnourished and we
don't look like anyone else for no particular reason. For no particular reason. Have you had
fish and chips in Melbourne? Aye and it's rubbish. I'm sorry. It's not haddock. We have haddock in
Scotland in the first time. I had a fish and chip here and it was minging. I was like I'm not eating
that again so I can't eat it because you guys have gummy shark or something. Although I'll give you
one up for anyone that's Australian. When you have takeaway, like fish and chips takeaway,
they make it fresh like batch whereas in Scotland they put it in the band marie which is the
heating up device machine thing in Melbourne. They put it in a band marie and just let it sit for
extra amount of time type thing. Sorry I farted. 83% Britbong fish and chips is poor. Literally I'll
miss that about in Scotland. The brain rot is too deep in the reason. Thank you tiny spadey.
Honestly. If it's perfect for you, it may not be perfect for you but perfect for you.
Okay so now we need to go back to Legolas and the gang gang gang gang because he's now looking
at Mount Doom so we can't progress as Sam and Matt. As I said this is why this game is like really
well made. It's like they literally thought that was someone please think of the lore implications
please stop this madness. This is literally me. This reminds me how much I love Lord of the Rings.
I like fantasy especially when there's like no capitalism fantasy. I said it sorry I said it.
I just want a nice cosy poverty. Imagine being nice and pally and your neighbours and that.
The worst thing that happens in your day is like a wee bit of gossip or something.
That's the life and you share your produce with each other and just it's peaceful. They're out
gardening all what you up to the day and it's like same old same old boring shit and just like oh it's
a peaceful life you know reading books and just I got my Gimli, I got my Vigo, I got my books,
I got my Reefland. You know that's the simplest. We don't want riches beyond our wildest means.
We don't want you know XYZ brainwashing from its future.
No Pippin! Pippin!
Pippin! Help! Gannops!
Fool of a Toke!
Fool of a Toke! Sorry I veered that squeak when I'm leaning into.
What did you see?
There was a white tree. It caught the other stone. It was dead.
Dun dun dun. It was a premonition of his attack.
Just cracked my neck.
Don't do that. Don't crack your neck. Hydration and posture check. Oh my yep.
Still a little posture of a shrimp. Thanks for checking.
Hydration absolutely awful. My hands are sweating. They're glistening. Actually speaking of glistening
hands. Wipe it on my motherfucking napkin. Just gamer girl problems.
See you're a guy. You wouldn't understand how hard we gamer girls game.
We get sweaty hands because we're so into it. Our feet literally ripping. You cannot comprehend
how deeply into a game that girls game. I'm sorry it has to be this way.
Really? What the fuck am I even on about? I'm losing it. Right where the heck are we?
So we did that cuts. Oh we're doing the hall of the dead. Yes I see it. Up there's the hall of the
the hall of the dead? I mean maybe the crypt of the dead. We're about to get the ghost army.
I hear feet dripping. Say less let me join. Are girls just chronically dehydrated or something?
I have attributes on why I'm dehydrated but I wouldn't be surprised if it's a
shared trait. Wouldn't be shocked if it's a shared trait. We're like fucking pet hamsters that
just perish randomly like before these particles. I'm so dehydrated.
Never forget that Tuk family are a fey blood which is a magical being in their lineage is
entirely possible. Pippin is Gandalf's great-great-great-grandson and that's why he tolerates the
fillery. Six thousand. Less than half of what I'd hoped for. Six thousand. We ride to death.
You making the sound wait six years? We're for any case you know.
Girls just randomly moving. Dun dun dun. The horses are spooked. Like if an animal is spooked out
listen to that motherfucking thing they know a lot more than we do.
Who's behind there? Who's behind the cape?
Oh my god face reveal.
We don't have any.
Get some water if you feel dehydrated. Can't put it dry as a cold.
What kind of army would linger in such a place? One that is cursed. Long ago the
men of the mountain swore an oath to the last king Gondor to come to his aid to fight but when
the time came when Gondor's mood was dire they fled vanishing the darkness of the mountain
and so we soon do a custom never to rest until we have fulfilled their pledge.
The way is shown. Magic's already quick to special though. It's glowing.
Dun dun dun we're going to through the mountain. Secret secret ghost army.
Right now this is the most annoying level okay so there's little things on the ground that'll
suck you in if you are silly enough to stand on them okay and it just holds up the gameplay
so dramatically. I'll see if I can point out where one is but see those like little air vents
suction things if you stand on it it holds on to you for so long and it's so frustrating
like bruv I'm just trying to play the game please let me go and it'll do it every single time you
stand on it and it's everywhere in this map. I will fart on the eyelashes of the game developer
who put that in because I have to admit that was that was low bro that was low and you got
void getting sucked literally. I'm not here for the suck right now. I'm trying to speedrun
I'm the fastest fastest person to play this game which is absolutely nonsense but I'm still the
fastest player like I can see the suck I'm avoiding it at all costs. And then it's time for you
and it's time to try hard and then it's time to do this and then push this down so we can get
Gimli to come up here and we'll build a ladder you want you want me to show you the suck it's so
bad I'll show you it when I come across one then it's just such a tame waste and I'm like
please I'm on my knees please okay so I don't know if Gimli naturally perishes at this point
this so this happens every time and you're stuck it's just like literally so annoying
so you have to avoid everything at all costs avoid them all
no if I'm not let's stay down
actually spotted that don't think I didn't see that purple gem okay I didn't see
any percent speedrun is one hour no that's glitches that's glitches out the wazoo one hour
how can anyone do this in one hour the cutscenes alone must make up 50 percent of that speedrun
that is impossible that is not possible what kind of glitches are people brah I need to watch the
speedrun after we do this because we're playing we're playing more tomorrow like we're gonna 100
percent tomorrow we were just gonna do the campaign today but that is outrageous one hour
and how much did that speedrun of lego lord of the ring set you back and it was that is a very
specific mirror it's like the there's a guy and he's like how much how much did that fresh
Rolex set you back and she says an hour and he goes and what but he says it like
feed him up feed him up feed him up feed him up money money money
it's tomorrow going to be speedrunning no no no we're literally going to replay
through the game but as the characters like the free play the free play so we can actually do it
I always mess up this section I never remember what I'm supposed to actually do
oh this sword just poked me
uh I think there's also a treasure under here oh well there you go yeah okay thank you memory
you're welcome yes my brain when it comes to remembering important information
nonexistent my brain to remember the hidden treasures that annoyed me that one time I played
the game oh you'll have to toss me
take them take them
okay then put them down and do this and then we are
we're all done crawling something everybody tosses the door just like me for room
uh I would like jump you up and down on my knee and stuff because you're like smaller than me
which makes it a lot easier to do stuff to you what I didn't mean it like that I meant like
you know I don't I've got weak arms and stuff like I can bounce you on my knee and like do all the
like a lord of the rings what was from the past yeah you're welcome
who knew this feature would be so based in her game choices if you ignore blinks
we are currently on the third movie and we are about to acquire oh can be scared
we're about to acquire the third
the third no we're about to acquire actually you don't want well we're at it
legolas can shoot these so we don't need to come back and do this
wait why am I getting plagued with enemies ghosts leave legolas alone I need to use them for this
can he even reach that other one
yes though
oh now he's getting stop it they they both get bothered by the ghost but
Emily uh Aragorn doesn't
I keep wanting to call him Viggo because of my cat I mean it is his name I'm not I mean I'm not
wrong but you know what I mean okay we're about to acquire the ghost army
me now you must die I didn't know this would work are you doing more like a game
mostly oh sorry sorry sorry um star wars definitely do star wars um I'm not sure about
hobbit as well I'm going to do the hobbit because I like hobbit
where did that come from what
that treasure was that delayed from the sniping thing I did with legolas
that took a sweet ass turn
wait he's coming to laugh at me I'm beating you up over here boom take that that's what I think about you
trying to hot me in my pals I think so that's right get spanked get spanked
well you think you you think you're good you think you're special no you're mine
you you belong to me I am the king of gondor the rightful heir of gondor
okay this is annoying because you need to do the platforms
yeah he'll like jump up on non-existent platforms and it's like please no no please
no no beat him up beat him up beat him up spank him
if he beat me up stop it he's beating me up too stop stop I need to do it I need I need to get him
in particular no one else okay no one else go away go away okay hold on hold pause I needed to build
up sweet okay is it three shot or is it four shot is it four shot come here right now come here
right now and I'll beat you the fuck oh okay we got it it was four he said have you played like
a batman does it count if my little cousin not blood related but my little cousin was like six
years old on his like nintendo df uh oh no he must be younger than that I don't know and he played
lego batman and he couldn't figure it out and he was like scrawny how did you know what to do
and I was like oh I played other lego games and he was like there's other lego games and I'm like
yes you will soon learn you'll soon learn how much games are waiting for you because you're so young
you have no clue how many games are sitting waiting for you to play um yeah yeah we scorn
we did it we have an army and we got kicked out via skulls lego batman yeah I don't know if I doubt
the ds game is like nn like that but
yes it's time
it's time the path of the dead okay close enough what did I say the walk of the day I don't know what
I'm for oh I'm almost unlocked all this shedding thirst that was three unlocks
and diana jumped with salada maybe I should go that I shall I did play the first thing but I don't
know if there's more than that we are at half a million studs I don't think we're gonna get a
million by the time we do the campaign mode unless there's one that's just randomly like
tons of them I have no idea we got 20 mithril though so we can make we can smith some
stuff in particular if someone has a request for it like I'm pretty shamed
I have left instruction
the people are to follow your rule in my step you've got 19,000
is that uh buddhams on the reef link I'll give you a buddhams for that that was good that was good
3ds had amazing arp again half a million the long road ahead one since I'm here oh my god that's
okay that's good that's good that's good and
okay let's go we're gonna break everything the one good thing about being on horseback
is you can like destroy stuff and pick up a lot more coins especially if you have stud attractor
you pick up a lot more coins and it's so good it's so so good right now this one glitches out a
lot so fingers crossed we don't get the glitch fingers crossed we on a wee pony he must oh he
must have a sore throat because he's a little horse
wait wait wait did I mess up that joke
wait did I mess up the joke did I say that he was a little pony or a little horse I
like I messed up the joke anyway hold on a minute hold on a minute did I mess up
the sentences I think he's got a sore throat because he's a little horse and in English
I look we say like horse throat if you've been talking too long
and stud attractor I didn't know you were an upgrade in this game oh
you guys get smooth what's going on here
no you said it right okay thank you
well
okay hell easy for you to say Gandalf you've got magic
You can be a little hocus pocus, and you're halfway across the map.
Stangyard Grund, man! Stangyard Grund!
Sorry, it's not that bad.
That was a straight up, huh?
The Riders of Rohan!
No, no, is this not the man of...
No, it is the Riders of Rohan. Sorry.
Whatever happens, stay with me. I'll go to you.
I like how they shot the mustache one.
Right now!
Elephant!
The Ruin and the Wild Dandy!
It hit the horse like, oh, excuse me.
Okay, the boxes! Fuck the boxes!
Okay, there's three boxes.
I'm fucking going mental trying to find these boxes.
I can't see them, and the camera is changing angle.
I'm getting nervous, I'm getting shaky.
I see it, I see it, I see it.
See that, see that camera angle.
See that camera angle?
You think you can outdo me?
Sorry, I've played this game too much.
I might have failed four other times previously,
but this time, no.
I will win.
Do you understand?
I win, you lose game.
I know exactly where the boxes are.
I don't, I think it's to the left a little.
A little to the left.
Oh, I don't know, I can't see it.
I actually can't see it.
I can't see it.
I'm tryharding to find the last spot.
There it is!
I'm coming!
Nope, that wasn't it.
We got played.
Oh no, the box!
Okay, forget the stud.
Get the stud.
Okay, I'll take that.
Where's the box?
Oh, the box!
The hitbox gave us it.
I love this game.
Oh, what did?
We accidentally just picked one up.
I didn't even do anything for it.
I love this game.
I didn't have to do anything.
All of them girl gins for real.
Come on, come on!
Come on!
I will kill you if you touch it.
The horse nodded in agreement.
Okay, this is where it glitches out a lot.
So please, video game.
I urge you, video game.
Don't be a meanie-boobie-nee.
Don't be mean.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't do anything.
It glitched out.
Do you see I'm running on the dragon?
No way!
It glitched out on the dragon.
This is, I don't know if I need to restart or I need to do this opening sequence again.
I'll quit.
And then we'll go back in the instance.
And if it's still broken at that sequence,
we'll have to close the game and open it up again.
It's very buggy.
It's very buggy on the dragon for some reason.
I think because it's a lander.
Oh!
I mean, no, no.
No, okay, let me, let me close the, uh,
quit to win this.
We're talking to game quit to win this.
Oh, my screen went black.
So hopefully you don't see anything you're not supposed to see.
Uh, right.
Let's try that again.
This is the instance thing I was talking about where the game is like XD.
Oh, my screen's black again.
So it was nice on you.
Please, OBS, register the game without me having to change anything.
Yes!
Oh, thank God.
Right, so it will work now.
For some reason, the longer the game goes on for,
the more, you know, memory leakage and stuff happens.
It is perfectly natural when the game does that.
We might have to play the horse sequence again,
but for us, it's not a big deal.
What's that folder?
Technicals kind of open?
No, no, no, no, don't open that one.
Don't open that one.
I used to be obsessed with technicals when I first discovered, um,
you know, um, I don't know why I was so obsessed with it.
And then it went away, but now that I'm,
I have to admit, now that I'm a little cult fish,
I'm like, I'm interested again, you know?
Oh, man, he used to be, right.
We're going to skip because we've done this before,
so we're going to skip.
Um, but as I said, we should,
should be all good in glory and we know what to do.
Uh, if, uh, if I'm not daft enough and miss a box somehow,
then I don't.
I'll just spam X anyway.
It seems like it's prompting me to spam the spears for some reason.
Um, and saying Lord, you're up, true and real.
What happens if I was going to be a cult fish all along?
I wonder what video started that all.
I think it was just, I like the idea of like uncontrollable
thing does thing to you.
And that's where it kind of came from.
From, I don't know where I got the last thing, by the way.
The last treasure.
It just kind of happened.
I wasn't paying attention.
Okay.
Yeah.
It just happens naturally.
That's fine.
Um, and like I watched, uh, I watched.
No, it was like this comic.
It's a really good, high rated series.
What a comic or some man go.
God, you can literally tell in such a game or a weeb.
Um, and it was, it's this series.
It's about that plot where, um, she's like,
is it a, she visits like a tentacle shop where it sells tentacles of different variety.
And then I think she ends up working there by the end of the series.
There's probably a few more installments, but you might know what I'm on about.
I don't know.
It's not an animation.
Right.
Please don't, please don't glitch out.
I'm going to cry.
Please don't glitch out because I don't know what to do if you do.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Let him get up.
Okay.
He's moving.
He's not doing the running animation in the seat.
Come on.
Come on game.
No, no day elite.
Come on.
Only the first time I played this game.
Nine hours.
Does Mary need to do it?
Does he need to be brave?
What's going on?
We're going back and forth.
You're making me nervous.
You're making me nervous game.
I need to do something.
All right.
I need you to do something.
I need you to fight me.
I'm getting nervous.
He's not even attacking me.
The only time I'm happy an enemy attacks me
is literally because he's not glitching out.
Okay.
He should smash his head down next.
We're doing it.
He's not glitched out.
Let's get to it.
You're pushing me back with his wings.
My wings are like a hurricane.
Did you guys watch the behind the scenes on making the Hobbit?
Benedict Cumberbatch was like method acting the dragon and they had to import like some very
particular like will of an animal or something to get him to shuffle about to get the cleanest
noise possible while he was doing the method acting and he was like in this suit on top of this
like a fluff type thing.
Oh no, his head didn't get bashed.
Okay, there we go.
And like Peter Jackson's like I was rather odd didn't expect that.
I think it's that beneficial cucumber.
Yes, exactly.
Bless you for streaming so long like on watch after work.
Had a bad day.
Turn wind to some leg was nice.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm sorry to hear that you had a shite day at work.
Honestly, Dinny, the one question I ask you right now, do you get paid enough to give a
shit about what happened at work at home?
And the answer is no.
Okay, you look after yourself and do what you need to do to feel better.
If that's food, if that's hydrating, if that's taking a 30 minute post-work job,
you do that and make sure you look after yourself because sure as hell,
your work ain't going to look after you with their fucking minuscule paycheck that they give you.
Oh, we slayed the beast.
Now it's time to deal with it and clock out forget work.
If I'm taking a job, I'm doing it on the clock.
I love, I love that so much.
Okay, now we need to build these platforms.
So this is like the troll at the start and where he goes on the platform.
So I'm going to grab these purples.
I'm going to sneeze.
So I'm going to sneeze.
So he does that and then you jump away.
And then again with the EO, let him swing.
He'll scream and then that's him locked in and then just wallop on.
And then break this up and then this might be the last one.
Yeah, that looks like it.
Okay, there we go.
Last one.
So you hear the scream move away and Bob's your uncle answer Fanny time for the cut scene.
And then you need to get him to beat him up.
I think.
Oh, oh, maybe not.
No, he hurt himself doing that.
Yeah, bless you.
The place like a balloon latex bros are winning in that scene.
Your thumbnail just gave me an idea.
What about Lego mini figurines of all the veiler girls as merit?
We can't get the rights to Lego.
Hey, is that an asset used from Pirates of the Caribbean?
How dare they?
I can't believe it.
Can't believe the reuse of assets.
Beat him up.
The army of the dead.
I can't wait for them to remaster Lord of the Rings in the Hobbit.
I don't know who they'll get to play them.
But I can just just know that in the future when you hear that the official remasters are coming out,
just know that I'll be an old wee granny and to my billion cats and I'll be happy.
Fuck, you just feel like goddamn.
I remember that strongy.
She was a fucking freak.
And you loved it.
So you need to put the arrows on so you can climb up and then basically just
go around the other way.
Can you cheeky doodle and jump up here?
You can.
I'm 50-50 on the remaster.
I honestly wouldn't mind seeing it if they pimped it the fuck out and actually put the funds
behind it and it wasn't a cash grab remaster.
I would love to see Lord of the Rings.
Where am I?
Am I stuck on the elephant?
I'm on the elephant's ball sack.
I don't know if you saw that, but I was currently stuck on the ball sack of an elephant.
So that could have gone better.
I'm going to be honest.
It could have gone better.
Okay, I need to somehow slash his anchors.
That's the first time that's ever happened to me.
I have to admit.
Spank his head.
Not the elephant.
Go back home to wherever you can somehow sufficiently enrich your body because you're
so large, the amount of calories you would need at any given day is astronomical.
Like whales.
Yeah, I don't know how whales eat plankton and still like nutritionally their body.
It doesn't seem like it would work out in theory.
So there's three more Oly fans going to enter Ministeris.
They're going to attempt to enter Ministeris, but the problem is we're in the way.
First things first in the argon one.
So when she spank the legs, feed them up.
Feed them up.
Eat them up.
There's a lot of plankton.
Swim around with her mouth open.
Me at the convention.
Maybe I should be in a wheelchair.
Okay, that's one of them.
Next one is currently waiting in line.
Oh, and it's another argon one.
Okay.
I'm not complaining because all I have to do is hit X on argon's ones where the
Legolas actually have to have like some mild input.
Imagine not having the literally background to understand the style of English and written
would use man to mean human change and they'll manage them to get higher turn rate for the
franchise.
Look, it is what it is.
No, no, no.
Don't turn it.
Don't turn around.
Okay.
Now you can do it.
Let me up.
Other way.
Yay.
And then other way.
Then up we go.
Maybe.
Then I said easy peasy.
And then I believe that is the defense of Minas Tirith.
Then is it just Mount Doomin?
I thought it was about to fall off the map.
Hug on achievement.
That all of them is Legolas.
It still only counts as one as the achievement name.
We already did that.
Did we not?
I don't know.
The army is now going through Minas Tirith and protecting the
out of it.
Oh no.
He's going to pop his wee clogs, his wee Lego clogs.
Oh, I love when they do that.
I'm so sorry.
I love when they do that stuff in the
like in Lego.
No, he's gone.
No.
He's called Leifeler.
The horse came back up again.
Gandalf.
Oh no.
He's traumatized.
There's a black gate fight and then is it Mount Doom?
And that's it.
We've done.
Chance is a success.
What are we waiting for?
Oh, the battle of Hell in our field.
I guess that's what's called right outside Minas Tirith.
I think there's two missions to go.
One's called the black gate and the last one's called Mount Doom.
And we've done it.
We've done it, ladies and gentlemen.
I don't know if Mercy is coming on.
I may be able to or maybe I don't know as a result of this.
Mercy might be on question mark.
Question mark.
Oh my god.
We literally only have two unlock cards.
The last one today.
No.
No, no, the treasures could be mildly hotter.
We're not going to like.
We have a few more treasures.
Gimli's just me.
Certainty of death.
Small chance of success.
Well, let's go for it.
He literally said send it.
Oh my god.
Gimli is such a zoomer.
All right.
Is this the second last one?
It may be.
I'm not sure.
Or is there one in here?
I don't know.
My brain is failing me right now.
Actually, sorry.
I have to admit, the meeting was quite eye-opening.
So we've got a lot of me more in here.
We've got a lot of me more in here.
Um, we've got a lot of me more in here.
Can't believe it.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I have to think.
Oh, I just can't.
Oh, I just teleported right on my butthole.
Um, yeah, I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
I have to think.
Oh, it's just terrible news.
It's the most, it is.
Oh, we just can't do it.
Where are we going?
Am I supposed to be Frodo right now?
We are going on an adventure and a half.
Are we backtracking to the black gate?
Why are we going through the swan?
Get off the horse.
What?
Where is it taking?
Right.
Hold on.
Hold on a minute.
Right.
You are taking me to the black gate,
but you're taking me like the most weirdest way ever.
We're literally having to go through the swamp
to get to the black gate.
No, Legolas.
Obviously, you're supposed to jump onto the island.
What does that already mean?
Yeah.
Already considering Leos.
Real and true.
I can't believe the vealers falling
far to the tomb on black.
He needs a skeleton key, I think,
if I remember correctly.
So let's pop you.
And then we'll make it to the black gate.
Wait, I could have teleported?
I could have teleported to avoid all that.
You know what?
Doesn't matter.
We're here.
That's the main thing.
We're at the black gate.
We're doing it.
Empty your head.
It's easier that way.
Real.
Making hypnosis for myself.
Or it's just emptying a month or nine or an hour.
You could just start drooling on yourself
because that would be, well,
that would be very nice.
And we sadly need to lay off.
Strongie needs to...
Strongie's being forced to go offline
because she's streaming every day.
Exy.
We're totally worried for her health.
Like, yeah, about you all.
We are going to discover this stone real quick.
But yeah, I think we're literally the black gate
and then mount them.
And we're done.
We did it.
For Frodo.
Take part.
Like, the guys are playing.
We need to sadly...
Sexual menace and deviant to society.
The what gate?
Black.
What is that bad word?
That the lord of the black line come forth.
Come forth, game.
Hear ye, hear ye.
I demand to speak to the monster.
You know you're still streaming.
You know, Strongie has to stay.
I can't stay online forever.
I'm going to perish.
I'm going to try and go for a walk, I think.
Men of the West.
Oh, it's for Frodo.
This is the part I always, like, start choking up in the movie.
I can't handle it.
Can't handle it.
I'm going to vomit.
Right.
There are archery targets in the back.
If I can just very quickly get them so I don't have to do it
when I come back to replaying
because I'm always going to end up forgetting.
Where is Gimli?
Gimli.
Honestly, my cat's been made a little outside the door.
I'm not going to be surprised if I open the door
and she's just staring at me like, you keep calling.
I called five times.
Right.
AI time.
So we're standing on it.
Roar.
Jump.
Okay.
I missed it.
I missed it, but that's not the point.
That's not the point.
I thought I had to do the arrow bone arrow thing.
No, don't start getting nauseated.
Do you know we've still got like another two hours or something?
Don't start vomiting on me, young man.
You're not a soft pan.
Right.
Stop getting...
Beat these up so we can build the next thing for him.
Oh, destroy what's in front of you, Legolas.
Please, darling.
I'm trying.
Right.
There we go.
We've got the building thing.
Only two hours.
Oh, sorry.
Which five hours?
I've really...
Have I got used to used to like the 12 hour endurance?
Okay, there we go.
He's going to wallop himself and then something else is going to happen.
Okay, hour gone time.
We're pre-throwing up.
No.
Not for Bambino.
I'm getting beaten up by us.
We need to destroy the orange.
Not to be confused with the door hinge.
I think I've spoiled too much.
Oh, sorry.
I just hit Gandalf in the back with an arrow.
Sorry, old man.
Didn't mean that one.
Like, see how the lava is blowing up in the background at Maldun?
Things are getting ready to blow.
Oh, no, please.
No more of these.
They glitch out all the time.
Please.
No more.
I can't take any more.
What am I supposed to do with them?
Or is it like last time?
Please don't glitch out.
I beg.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Uh, I can see the point on his chest that I'm supposed to hit.
Okay, good.
As if I just supposed to do that.
Oh, he disappears already.
Y'all meant for glitches and things.
It's because you mentioned woman.
Because, you know.
Look, we're little babies.
What am I going to do with you?
What's going to happen when I actually need to break?
Like, if I released the schedule and it said I was taking a day off,
is it like complete meltdown?
Like, are we in major trouble?
Or, um, oh, I can't do anything here.
Uh, because I'm going to start getting worried that, uh, it's not, uh,
you guys aren't going to do, feel so good if I take a day off.
Like, I'm still going to be crazy enough to try and stream every single day.
And for a year.
But it is plausible.
You know, my health is going to catch up to me to the point.
Severe depression.
No, you're not.
Oh, are you?
We scorn means a lot of cleaning up from me.
But if you do that three times, no, he's already slain.
The day starting takes a day off.
I'm going to get so much done.
Please don't get sick.
I'm going to, I'm changing my
jaw yet.
And I'm going to knock off the takeout.
Uh, I'm going to try and up my natural exercise,
like going outside and just for a walk and stuff.
And I might be able to grab more seats, actually, like a week.
That's right.
If you see, if you see me entering your garden, no, you don't.
No, you don't.
I need the seats more than you do.
Okay.
I need them more than you do.
I would cry, but I would cry harder if let me hurt.
I'll be in the trenches if you go.
I mean, in theory, if I really was going to take, like,
a considerable time off, like three days off in a row,
I kid you not, I could very most likely record,
like, Valtro and ASMR type thing.
So it's not, wait, how do I take your armor off?
How do I take his thing off?
Does he need to smash the ground or something?
I can't, bro.
I can't 1v1 you.
You're like massive.
Okay.
He just gets tired.
Understandable.
Have a nice day.
Okay.
He just gets tired of swinging.
Oh, ow.
Ow, he got me.
Three days off consider.
I mean, I don't know.
I think for me, for my standard is like three days off is like,
yeah, I would get tons of stuff done,
but I don't know if I would, like, mess it up.
Just let it ink one more time before you go, though.
A little serotonin boost before it's all gone.
We can always post the video and take it.
Yeah, like, I think if I were to do anything,
if I could feel myself bubble into the surface and be like,
right, that's me done.
I need, like, a few days off.
I could definitely, in exchange, do, like,
I could record gameplay of me playing, like, a round of balutril.
And it's just me, like, going absolutely 8 checks.
I'm so happy that I won it, basically.
I bet I did it on my own.
Did you see?
I won on my own.
I didn't need you guys to do all the math for me.
I cheated.
And, like, I can record, like, the ASMRs and edit them.
Like, this isn't a problem if I did take time off.
I mean, at the rate I'm going, I'm still okay.
You know?
It's still gonna work.
But I'll let you go, and I'll get your opinions and feedback and stuff.
But I do...
The two hour streams is weird as it was not being online for two hours.
More than two hours.
I might incorporate them slightly more.
I'm gonna, I'm testing them out next month.
You're gonna know exactly what ones I'm talking about.
There's a new Deadpool movie?
Off to go see the new Deadpool movie.
Gonna watch the rest of stream tonight.
BTW, it's Stephen Burns like Stephen Hillberg.
I don't know how Stephen Hillberg is said.
Stephen?
Stefan?
Thank you for the tip.
I hope you enjoyed Deadpool, by the way.
I didn't realize I had a new one.
Smelly today.
Absolutely sweating and putrid, my good sir.
I've been nonstop sweating on this game.
Not even kidding.
Thank you, Cluffy Nutter.
And thank you, Stephen, Stephen.
I'm just gonna say all variations until, you know, one of them works.
Like Stephen with a V, right?
Yeah, see?
I'm so sorry, but you know how you literally put Stephen with a V?
I don't mean it in a mean way.
I'm telling you.
Strani, take off three days.
Get five months of work done in those three days.
Didn't relax any moment of it.
Right, that's a little, one, anonymous.
Don't call me out like that.
Cause two, that's a little too,
that's a little too on the nose of exactly what would happen.
I would wake up later than stream time.
And then, I can't believe you said the quiet part out loud.
Why would you do that to me?
You've just embarrassed me.
Did I look at this?
I think so.
Oh no, there's more.
Hydration break.
Let me finish my water.
Cause I think this is it, Rieflin.
Rames with even, Stephen.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
See?
I got it.
I'm sorry.
I did it.
In my defense, in the English language,
a pH maker F sound, okay?
So don't blame me.
Spank your own morn, your paw, okay?
Don't spank me.
Spank them.
Mommy's too much in love with her.
And too much of a workaholic.
Okay.
Let's just say once I've dealt with my 100
VTuber collab series, if you want to call it that,
and my 100 ASMR, thank you, reward goal.
Things will be just that.
That's going to be nice all of all.
Cause you stream all the time.
We know you're everywhere.
Her Frodo, he's absolutely just gone by this point.
Yeah, look at, oh no.
He's so lifty.
Look at the way he's walking.
If you don't-
Oh.
For a while, we will be in the trenches.
I promise to take care of my fellow brothers
for you.
You have my words, mommy.
I don't want everyone throwing up
and being upset that I'm not online.
It's not happened yet.
I'm not at my point yet.
But I will let you know, like,
I'm not really going to hide it if I'm not well.
I don't want to, like, I don't, you know,
I don't have to rant about
it.
Sorry, I just got absolutely walloped.
I didn't know I expected that.
Sorry, I need you to-
Thank you, reverse, for the super chat.
Frodo, it's like he's missing mommy too.
Like, I'll tell you if it ever gets too much,
but like, put it this way,
she be quite literally said in the group chat,
Strone, in the meeting, sorry.
She literally said, like,
Strone, you need to be careful.
And I'm like, yeah, you know what,
you know what, that's true.
That's true.
You're kind of right.
And I'm like, okay, I don't know.
I'd really, I just really like the idea
of streaming every single day, though.
Like, I want that to be, like,
one of the insane accolades of this,
you know, that I managed to achieve.
Like, I streamed every single day type thing.
And then I worked behind the scenes
every single day type thing, you know?
If you knock that over, you get a little chest.
I don't know how you're supposed to figure out
on your own, but there you go.
Everyone needs a Sam.
You're my Sam, refling.
Weird, rather, if you did three arrests,
then you burned out.
I don't, oh, see, this is where I'm like,
I don't get burned out the way people describe it.
I get tired.
Don't get me wrong.
I get, I'm a tired bean.
But like, the terminology burnt out.
I'm like, if I'm burnt out,
just pick a game that I like.
Like, I'm rearing to go against Sam.
Are you coming over?
Okay, yeah, come on.
Oh, he did it.
He did it.
He's fine, he's fine.
Like, if I ever felt burnt out,
I think it's just because I'm being shite, you know?
I'm a me, hi, people.
Sam, please come through the tunnel.
Hi, Mama.
I just got back from work and I'm glad to be here.
I hope you're doing well,
and if not, I'd like you to take some time
for yourself every now and then.
Thank you very much, Flashpower.
I hope you enjoyed your work.
Wait a minute, you just finished work.
Did you send that while doing your post-work job?
I dare you.
I'm on to you.
How dare you do that?
Thank you very much, though, for the super chat.
And let me pop in your super chat chair.
Yank my now.
Thanks for your boy chair.
Short streams, counter streams as well.
Yes.
The only problem is there's not many games
that interest me that are super short.
I'm like, so when my dad was here,
we played like Sa-ku-i-ya.
Wait, what's going on here?
I don't know what I need to do with you.
We need to go off?
And what would Sam being up here do for me?
I don't know.
Oh, he can do something ahead.
Yeah, like those short two-hour streams,
the wham-bam things, I've definitely got more of those
planned like ASMR streams or two-hour wham-bam.
Sa-plan-pou-moi.
Sorry, that song has wham-bam, motoplan.
I think I may have a few more of those planned.
Like originally I was going to play Shadow of War,
but I'm a bit nervous.
It's going to go pish, wakafo-ish.
And I'm sorry, I didn't want that.
Let's get you over here.
All right, and then you go on that.
And then I'll push you over.
And then you're going to go behind.
And then you're going to do this.
Okay, but wait a minute.
Why is the camera angle so tight?
It needs to, maybe there's something hidden
at the bottom of the map right here.
Oh, how did I know?
It's fine, I'm just so able to do.
I just know everything about this game.
Can you jump up?
Thank you.
And then we're going to go up the top.
And we're going to go beat up Gollum.
Wham-bam, thank you, ma'am.
Okay, now we're going to go beat Gollum up,
because he's up here.
Those games are short and they have easy moves.
Hello, leggy, stroney.
Did you like my thumb?
Oh!
Come on, Mr. Portal.
Oh, no, that's what always makes me cry as well.
But I can fly.
But I can't carry you.
Come on!
Oh, my God, Sam.
No, Gollum, not no.
So, because we're so weakened right now,
Gollum can technically take us on.
You know, lack of food, lack of just everything.
You're a cheeky sod, you are, Gollum.
You really are.
What did I do?
I threw a rock at him.
Fuck you, Peach.
Sorry, that was really funny the way he just accepted that.
Just the rock being tossed at him.
Fuck you, Peach.
No, we can't both be throwing rocks at each other.
Only I can throw the rocks.
No, don't throw them at me.
I'll throw them at you.
Fuck you.
No, you're too far away.
Okay, Frodo has to angle it correctly.
No, take that.
Yeah, take that, you little shit.
Ah, get off of me.
Fuck you, Peach.
Oh, I imagine trying to fend off
when you just fall into the lava.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, now what?
Fuck you, no.
Fuck you, Peach.
Uh, and Peach.
Get off of me, Gollum.
You stinky boy.
Run, Frodo.
Run, Frodo, you can do it.
No, no, no, no.
Drop it, drop it, drop it.
Destroy it.
Not again.
The ring is mine.
No.
That's not the fly report to knock him out.
Okay, so Frodo and Gollum
and are fighting in the motherfucking ring world.
And then I need to go to fucking Sam
and smack him with a frying pan.
We are.
Okay, and then he'll make me drop off the map
at these segments.
And then I think we did it.
Definitely do not want to fall
into the crispy cavern below.
You know, I don't want to get
turned into human jerky.
And then we do this.
And then you have to manually jump up
with Sam.
The game won't do it itself, which is annoying
because I hate parkour in this game.
And then you can go back to Frodo
because he's getting attacked again.
And then you go back to Sam
and you'll wallop him.
You beat the absolute.
Take this.
No, get back here.
I'm not done with you yet.
Get back here, Gollum.
You stinky piece of cheese.
And then he jumps on your back
and you fall off and do it all over again.
We'll hobbit jerky, honestly.
I thought you'd like it
when Gollum jumps you in a minute.
Munko.
Gollum?
You think Gollum's my type?
Skinny and scrawny.
Skinny and scrawny for scrawny.
What's going on here?
Are you pranking me?
Okay, I pan.
It's happening.
The end is upon us.
The end is nice.
Okay.
And then we need to help Sam.
He's getting beaten up again.
And then, no, sorry, Frodo.
And then whack him with a frying pan.
You get off me.
You know, boy.
Gollum, knock it off, buddy.
Jesus, just leave him be.
You fellow beast.
You know not what the harm you cause.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Get off.
We'll build some emergency pieces for Sam.
And then we'll jump.
And then we jump.
And then we beat him up.
Beat him up.
It's a 1v1.
Okay.
Stick his whole hand.
Anakin style.
Oh wait, no.
No, Anakin.
The sun.
Luke Skywalker style.
Oh wait, Anakin doesn't have a hand either.
They both don't have hands.
Wait a minute.
Because one got burnt to a crisp
and the other got sandpicked.
Beat him up.
Come on.
Swing that ring.
Swing that thing.
Frodo, no.
Dolan got what he wanted though.
Imagine being addicted to something so much
that you do not feel the pain
of burning hot molten lava.
That's some real addiction.
Take that, you stinker tin.
Leave Middle Earth alone.
For the age of man is upon us.
Oh, I love that.
Frodo did it.
You did it.
Oh.
Forgot about that part.
I have to go over that part.
You.
I know this sweat drop.
Oh, no.
Wait, is this a runaway seat?
Is it left or right?
It has to be the right.
Oh, no, that far right.
It has to be the right side.
Is this a jump one?
It's a jump one.
I got it.
That's all we needed.
It was a jump one.
Surely it's on the right.
Whatever it is.
If there's anything more.
Is there anything more?
It's always on the right.
Doesn't matter what it is.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
We're safe.
Is it?
Oh, no.
Maybe it is on the right.
Hold on a minute.
I'm getting nervous.
I end before the last one is randomly on the left.
Look at the mountain just getting blown off in the background.
Okay, we're fine.
We got it.
We did it.
The lava will be overflowing.
It's gone.
Yes, Mr. Frodo.
It's over now.
It's all like that, people.
They forgot that third one.
Unplayable 0 out of 10.
Don't pass out now.
Yeah, I'd be pretty exhausted if I were you.
Not gonna lie.
Eagle girl for gent-
Oh, okay.
You win.
Now come the days of the king.
Oh, he'll flank them.
Yeah.
He's the king.
You did it.
Oh, the horsey horsey come in too.
He's happy.
This day does not belong to one man, but to all.
You bow to no one.
Your heart efforts didn't go away.
You did it.
Frodo weary unlocked.
I mean, I'm not sure we want weary, but sure.
I lie your words save the day.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I know everyone is unlockable end game.
We did it.
I'm so upset when my musicians only skinny refund.
You'll never guess what feeder of them is.
You're going to shit your pantyloons.
Pallet swap character.
Pretty much.
Although his ability is he can move less.
What?
Why are you giving me money for play?
Thank you for the 100.
That's big.
Thank you.
Finish story.
Let's see what the cutscene is.
Is there no cutscene to wrap it up?
Don't do that to me.
There's no cutscene.
Thank you, add on for the hundreds.
Johnny's heart efforts didn't go away.
No, we steamrolled the campaign.
Is there actually no cutscene?
There must be.
There has to be.
It's not just going to plot me in after all of that.
Chad refling.
Thank you again for the 100.
It's generous.
You'll be too generous.
I'm getting suspicious.
What are you expecting?
How do I repay you for this kind of money?
We depart with a million.
Cutscene locked behind a hundred percent.
Are you trolling or is that real?
Why are you so cute?
It's the autism.
And now you find are you really the best myth or item?
The firework.
Because it blows stuff up.
Is there not a Valinor cutscene?
I thought maybe there was like a boat scene.
You know, you know the whole sad ending on the boat?
Did they never put that in the question mark?
Surely they did.
Copying.
Michael Roberts.
Barry.
Trang.
Neil.
Liam.
Keith.
Chris.
David.
Debra.
Finn.
Guy.
John.
Alan.
Dominic.
Stewart.
Jonathan.
Andy.
Stefan.
Andres.
A.
Paul.
Ewan.
Stewart.
Duncan.
Richard.
Ellie.
How could I thank you all for putting this together?
David.
Craig.
Neil.
Sean.
Adam.
Holly.
Will.
Thomas.
Rob.
Carol.
Carl.
Jeff.
Charles.
Raymond.
Amador.
Stephen.
Stefan.
Good luck.
Thomas.
Tim.
Another Stephen.
Something.
Another Mark.
Another Jonathan.
Adele.
Edina.
Simon.
A.
Helen.
Paul.
A.
Tom.
James.
Stewart.
An Emma.
Robin.
A.
Richie.
James.
A.
Joe.
Christian.
A.
Chris.
An Abbey.
Darren.
Stewart.
How could I?
Yeah, I'll wave at this without you guys.
How could I fall in love?
I said Carl's so wrong there.
I was like, uh, the disco fail?
Oh, okay.
How?
How could we do this without all of you?
Bob.
What's your name?
B.
O.
So they call on you.
Bob.
Others call him Tim.
Carl.
What now, Strane?
What do you mean?
Now we get to play the game
because we get to the free mode.
But I'm going to save it for tomorrow
because I'm a bit emotionally drained today.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm emotionally drained.
I can't believe I'm a human.
I'm only human after all.
I'm only human.
Bob the Builder.
He's trying to call.
Can she fix it?
Bob the Builder.
And she can.
Scoop Muck and Daisy.
Join the crew.
Bob and the gang have so much fun.
Sign together and have a little fun.
Bob the Builder.
Can she fix it?
Yes, he can.
Fuck it.
All the credits are gone.
Thank you for always being there.
Very special thanks to
Lewis, Connor, Dan, Sam, Tom, and Aaron.
Or Aaron, depending on Aaron, Aaron, and Aaron.
TT Games Publishing.
Thank you for all your hard work
into the advertisement of this game.
Though you didn't have to advertise it
to people like me
because as soon as you slap Lord of the Rings on it,
I am sold, amen.
Lofty and Wendy.
Oh yeah, Wendy's his wife or something.
Oh my god, they're making me unlock memories.
I forgot there was a character like that.
A-A-Ron.
It's Aaron.
No.
Raphael.
How could I forget you?
Fabio.
Delicious.
Mike.
Jack.
David.
Ben.
Big Toby.
Toby Smith.
How could we forget?
Who could we forget?
We almost forgot what we did before.
Lego Company.
Big Jesper for setting it up.
Darryl for getting all the development approved.
Pair Nile.
Yep.
Sten.
Mm-mm, fantastic work.
Big Amanda.
Big Jacob.
Big Janny.
Demetris.
Yep.
Raymond, of course.
How could we forget Raymond?
Bob the Buildler or Fixit Felix?
Or Handymanion?
Fixit Felix.
Ain't that from Rick Ralph?
John.
How could we forget?
I feel like I'm reading the same names over and over.
Are they re-putting everyone's names in?
Baki.
Fantastic.
Alicia.
I'm starting to go mental.
I think I'm reading the same names.
Arian.
Big Lindsay.
Evelyn.
Jennifer.
Oh, why is it the Waman's Department is marketing?
How curious.
There's definitely more feminine chick names
in the marketing department,
but all the developmental stuff is like majority of guy names.
Don't think I didn't notice that.
Public Relations.
Someone's called Joy.
Good thing it's not with an I.
Renny.
Jennifer.
Yeah.
Information Technology.
Who Information Gatherers?
Adrienne.
Joshua.
Curtis.
Spencer.
Stefan.
Marvin.
Eric.
Michael.
Lurch.
He got his nickname or anything.
RJ.
Sales.
I'm going mental.
I've seen these names before.
I'm getting mucked about.
What's going on here?
I'm reading all these names before
because ladies know how to self-lease.
That was him.
Not me.
Yeah, maybe some hours before I go off of course.
Darling, I can do that.
And we'll find someone to redirect and to have that feel.
I won't stay for too long.
Because I will be brutally honest and say I'm pretty emotionally drained after that mean.
And also I need a fat ship.
So, you know, we must.
Must.
But tomorrow, basically what happens tomorrow
is we replay through all the missions and get 100% completion.
That will be done in one stream.
I am pretty sure I can do it.
I was about to ask about Maros too.
Okay, that worked.
Yeah, you've been here for five hours.
Yeah, so I had two hours with the girls.
And then five hours with you guys.
And I've got a lot to think about after, you know, what occurred.
Wow.
Tired moment.
Mom is getting sleep soon, maybe.
As for the reflinks who are on my Patreon again,
cannot thank you enough.
I pinky, pinky promise you.
Can't break a pinky promise that a grooming audio goes up.
That is a wild sentence.
It goes up.
I might take a nap after the stream, but it is going up.
Before I stream tomorrow, it will be up at some point.
I can't give you a time.
I can't give you hours.
If I fall asleep for a nap, I'm probably going to get four hours of a nap
and then have them, you know, come back and do all the bedding and stuff.
Okay.
Emotional drain to you instead of emotional damage.
If things go well behind the scenes,
then the partnership for established click channels will be announced.
If not, then I will focus on AC's ASMR roleplay,
because she's been waiting very patiently for me to pop that up.
Um, so very patient.
And I'm very paid for anything.
So as you can see, even though I'm 100% completely the campaign,
we've only got 23% completion.
That is blinding.
Is there really not a cut scene?
Oh my God, my emotional heart.
Oh my God, no, there's no cut scene.
How is my heart supposed to handle this?
There's no cut scene.
Right.
I think if you go back to the Shire,
you can go talk to Big Bilbo.
And the story's not even a quarter done.
I guess you're saying, where does the blue studs take me?
I have no idea.
I don't know.
But anyway, so this is our farm life.
Everyone's got their own Hobbit Homes.
Everyone's got lovely flowers outside.
And it's so beautiful.
And then we have parties as well.
We have nice little fairs where we dance.
And I'll teach you some Scottish waltzes and stuff.
Our most popular dance is called the Gay Garden.
I'll teach you.
And then we all nice to nature.
And we got all the carrots and all the produce
for everyone to celebrate.
And it comes from everyone's garden.
So we don't have to like, you know.
But yeah, we have a good time.
And then we've got a nice river where we can do fishing.
If we want to casually fish.
And then at night, we would go back to our house,
which is over here on the hill.
That's Rosie.
That's Sam's wife.
Hi Rosie.
That's Samwise's wife.
Because he has a wife.
He has a wife, he does.
And then this is Bag End and Zade.
And you can create a custom character in here.
I don't do it because I'm not a foster custom character.
But yeah, there's Bilbo if you want to buy him.
I'm going to keep the money for now.
But there's like the kitchen and all of that jazz.
Next stream we get 100% cutscene.
Wait, is that real?
Or are you guys trolling me?
I don't remember them being 100% cutscene.
Yeah, but yeah, we've got our little chimneys.
So there's like a nice little smell of smoke in the air.
Not that it's too much, but I might say that's okay.
Which fantasy world would you live in?
Hobbiton.
You know, once all the enemies are defeated type stuff.
Definitely Hobbiton.
And like you can also come back at night for the party if you want.
Because the party's even more impressive at night.
If it's working.
Sometimes it doesn't work and that's okay.
Yeah, there you go.
You can see the fireworks and stuff.
And they've got sprinklers for the party at night
with everyone in Hobbiton.
See?
And if you get Sam, you can do this.
You can set them off.
Yeah, it's really sweet.
I think it's a really nice little detail.
If you come at night time, you can set off fireworks.
Ta-da!
And our reward is money.
And we got a mythril break just for that.
There's like loads of really cool hidden stuff.
I think it was very sweet.
And yeah, everyone's just having a good time.
I would live if I had a chance to do it.
I've never seen Lord of the Rings,
but for some reason I remember someone explaining to me
why Samwise is gay.
He's not gay, what the fuck?
He literally marries a wife and has wings.
But yeah, I'm flinched out.
It shouldn't be here.
Okay, let me safely quit the game, save and exit,
just to make sure.
And then I'll look at some marshy-warshy mallows.
Oh, big stretch!
Oh, we did it!
Yep!
Look, there's Mary and Pippin running.
The carrots they stole.
There's Gandalf.
Why is there a pig fishing in the river?
Gandalf delivering his fireworks,
because he's more friendly.
He has 13 kids, he has four kids.
I'm seeing conflict and information.
What's going on here?
Everyone knows that Smashing Clown's the gay-
What?
What are you talking about?
Right, the game should pause,
because I'm not in it right now.
But I'll take it off the screen,
just so it's not like super distracting.
You're the game?
Okay.
And then I'll make myself big,
and then we'll go read some.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
I forgot I'm not supposed to-
Ah!
I'm not supposed to-
I do this all the time offline.
I'm not supposed to move the freaking window,
and I do it because did that work?
Oh, it worked.
Okay, I don't know how that worked,
but it worked.
Okay, let me refresh my phone.
I broke it.
I did that a little bit though.
Are you mentioning taking a break?
I'm going to be fine if you can break on time.
It's like someone's trying to stream for short streams.
You can do one, two hours at a time.
Yeah, I'm going to try it out.
I've got in the stream next month,
and it's like, are we compatible?
Now, before anyone actually throws up
in case you answer something wrong,
it's just for shits and giggles.
I'm going to ask questions,
that there's no way you're going to know about, okay?
Did I say 24% complete?
Yes, we completed the campaign mode,
but we've not got all the collectives,
so we need to go back and do that all.
And there's also missions in Middle Earth
where we have to give people quest items and stuff, okay?
So yeah, I'm not compatible.
No, no, no, it's for fun, okay?
I'm going to ask questions that you won't know.
I'll ask some questions that you might know.
Some will be basic.
Some will be very deep,
and I'll just straight up have to guess.
Like, you'll have no idea.
So don't worry, I'm going to practice.
I'm going to practice.
I'm going to look around and see about shorter streams,
but high-quality short streams.
Yeah, I realized I forgot to send you my Morrow morning.
I've been trying to say something every morning.
Yeah, morning, Reefland.
Love you, Stranny, love you, Reefland.
Don't worry, you don't have to send me every day.
But if you'd like to, yeah.
Would you be interested in Modern Elden Ring?
Seamless Co-op.
Yeah, I'm playing it with the...
Send sister, soon to you.
You can't just talk about your sweaty panties
and expect us to be okay.
I did have some more.
Please do more sent play audios.
Wait a minute, Reefland.
You've typed the same.
You're right, two back to back, okay?
With your sweaty, cute hands,
I could give you the most amazing hand.
I could give, but I don't...
Okay.
You could add a...
A savviette for the pineapple suggestion, Reefland.
Sweet pineapple and pizza.
Hi, Johnny.
Hi.
Hold on.
It's weird.
Sorry, not everything are going to be download.
Well, it's weird.
I feel like I have to correct myself here.
What?
Are you guys having brain worms today?
What's going on?
Okay, I don't understand.
Well, that's been called with all the messages, I guess.
Kind of.
Oh, just a few more.
And sent play.
Hey, woman.
You just want to say that when you get old,
you won't be surrounded by a thousand reflames.
Well, you're going to keep me alive.
Every time I pop my clogs,
you're going to do CPR on my ribcage.
It's going to be busted and broken.
That's actually cool.
I also have sweaty hands,
and it can be a pain.
Yeah, they're sweating right now.
It's actually been a bit uncomfortable to stream today.
This is probably the worst.
I've had it in a very long time,
but I'm quite stressed right now.
So that probably doesn't help in general.
Hello for me.
You've been such a light in my life.
I wasn't expecting.
Don't want to bring down the mood.
But you thought about end in the game,
and I've had a positive impact on you.
And I feel a love for you
that I haven't felt in a long time.
The world is a better place.
Oh, I think I'm glad we found that you feel better.
I love you too, darling.
Maybe be careful.
You can always pause the game,
but you close that game.
You close that XFile of the game,
or the, you know, the soger.
You have the most beautiful hands in the world.
Yeah, you want to touch my sweaty hands.
It's trying to have something important to tell you.
You're awesome, and we love you.
Oh, yeah, I love you too.
We will join the dark side,
if it means you can take mommy around.
You'd Anakin Skywalker for me?
You sprained your wrist to one of my audios?
Which one?
The tofu teacher?
You sprained your wrist?
Are you okay?
I mean, you know,
I do take a little bit of pride in my work,
but yeah, then you sprained your wrist over it.
A wreathling? You're a degenerate.
Please be careful, okay?
Don't hurt your wrist.
The women and the children.
I hate them.
Fledgely, you're on your Anakin sprain.
Hey, scrawny.
Same wreathling with the sweaty hands.
I'll gladly take the sweat off your hands, if you wish.
Also, may we wreathlings please have some kisses?
Yeah.
Now you have to imagine touching my sweaty hands
while we kiss.
And I get all embarrassed that they're sweaty,
but you're like, no, no, it's fine.
You want background music?
Is it deadly quiet in here?
I don't even have background music.
It's not in the files.
I've moved it.
So you're just going to have to listen
to my stinky voice in the dark, okay?
Actually, I'm going to see if there's anyone
we can redirect into.
As I said, I'm going to...
I can't believe we actually played
the label Lord of the Rings.
I know that sounds silly because I picked it,
but like, it's just like, I get to do whatever the...
I want, you know?
I get to do whatever the...
I want.
And it feels good, man.
It feels good, man, okay?
Oh yeah, have we redirected into these before?
I don't think we have.
Okay, we're going to redirect into her.
I'm being you today.
I must say, man.
Strange...
Strange refilling, identify yourself.
We may just throw it up as a meme,
but if your health actually ever demands
that it'll be fine, we'll miss you,
but I don't want you to be too listy.
As far as I'm concerned,
there's only one ring to rule them all,
and that's the ring in your bag to heart.
That's good.
Not that much of a reason.
Your voice is as stinky as your voice is.
Calm in.
Yeah, even when you get angry, it's scary,
but you're the reflin that said it the first time,
and then we made a meme of it too.
I want you to be okay, and I love you.
I promise I'm okay.
It's just like...
You know, things are going to resolve themselves,
but we're just in the awkward phase of like...
That...
This is the phase we're in right now.
Just...
That's the phase we're in right now.
That's the only way I can describe the phase I'm...
It's currently occurring right now,
and that'll be over with soon, right?
Every time he kisses me, he's happy.
I could listen to the whole stream and just kisses.
Oh boy, you're going to enjoy the membership
next ASMR membership stream.
I'm not allowed to talk until I do a thousand kisses,
because I keep saying I'm doing a membership ASMR,
and then I stop instantly.
So my punishment is 1,000 kisses in the next ASMR membership stream.
You're in this timing phase.
You've injured your right hand,
and your cute nurse helps you relieve your stress.
I like plots like that, honestly.
It's your phase, mom.
Is this thing live?
No, I'm sorry, it's pre-reported.
Are you squidding me right now?
Maybe.
I said it once, and he'll say it again.
I'm very grateful for this community,
and for Strani giving her time for us.
I'm always going to support you.
Thank you very much, okay.
I'm glad reeflings feel that way.
Even my boll heard it as.
I've been a silly boo, but...
Don't worry, you can use me as a sweat rag.
I wouldn't mind.
Oh dear, is that how you're going to get your electrolytes back?
Via my salty sweat?
We would...
We worry about you more than you.
We worry about being lonely when you're happy and healthy.
But I've got to look after you, reefling,
or else you're going to throw up.
I'm actually going to puke all over yourself,
and I need to get you cleaned up.
Maybe I should just straight up make an ASMR roleplay
of that, like you threw up in the middle of the night.
It's like, mom, I fool up.
And then I come clean you, and then I get you a bath,
and I tell you, you'll feel better soon,
and it's okay to be anxious.
And pukelings?
Oh no!
What have we done?
We've started something.
Yeah, I don't know if we might have just accidentally
started something.
Eep.
I'm also the reefling that ain't six times in a plan.
I'm doing it again.
Bruh!
That's gotta hurt.
I hope we make you as happy as we make the...
I mean, you certainly do.
I mean, shh.
Hey.
Forget about this ring, Strone.
I have one for you.
Aw, is that a marriage proposal?
But you didn't let me mind break you first.
Need a green puke and a moat now?
Actually, do you want that?
I don't know.
I don't know if that's a bit...
How can you look after us if you're down for the count?
I'm...
I don't get down for the count for long, though.
I'm gonna throw up.
Catch it.
Oh, I'm not gonna catch it.
Put it in the bin.
Get in the bin.
Lom it in the bin.
Don't lom it on me.
Lore at your emote.
We're gonna do puke emote, so anyway.
I like the nausea-emote combination,
where you post the,
ooh, and then the nausea face,
like, you're about to do it,
but you don't do it yet.
Um...
If you ever need us, tell us,
and we'll try our hardest to cheer you up.
We love you, seriously.
Oh, we do.
We love you, too.
Don't worry, everything...
Day, a billion of saying,
like, it's all gonna calm down.
Cover Strone in our love,
puke him, honestly.
Make a rainbow puke emote.
It's in TM.
Maryssey actually wanted one of those,
which was really funny.
And I'm about to order the next,
like, missing a boat for everyone.
And I'm doing a few things first
in the background before I get them ordered,
but I should probably do it sooner or later,
because we took their sweetest time.
They took my shoulders.
One of your audios actually made me hand-free ink,
and I've been chasing that high
ever since.
What the heck?
I didn't even know I had that, Billy.
H.F.O.
And, like, hypnosis is quite big.
I've wanted to try it,
but I don't know if I have the skills for that.
I don't know.
I'll consider it.
Ah, can't see any of it.
It would be an all-audio free access
all that does.
Hey, honey.
The same reason that ink and her say hands.
It doesn't hurt.
I just feel tired.
I can go seven times.
Oh, my God.
Just be careful.
You don't have a death grip, okay?
Peeler, we're short for pukeler.
No, it's just the reeflings that puke.
Everyone else can hold it together,
but, like, I was so late today.
Like, the meeting had just finished,
and it had gone a bit longer than I expected,
just because a few things popped up
that I didn't expect.
And then it was just chaos,
and I was like, oh, God, I need to make my tea.
It might be good for once you've levelled up
your hypnosis, though.
Eh.
And, right, my lovely jubbly reeflings.
I am going to go.
I hope you are okay.
Thank you for hanging and playing
one of my favorite games with me.
Tomorrow we're gonna 100% it,
and we're gonna have a new year time.
I love you.
I hope you'll be okay.
And I am redirecting to you
from someone from B&U,
and as always, I act my way.
They act their way.
You guys will be a good example,
I'm sure, for me, okay?
You'll be the goodest of boys with your example.
And we'll take it from there, all right?
Okay.
I say make sure she's online,
make sure she goes offline.
I swear she's wrapping up streams.
No, she's not.
She's still streaming.
All right, thank you so, so much reeflings.
I'll talk to you tomorrow.
I'll be a lot more energetic tomorrow, so, okay?
Okay.
See you tomorrow.
Bye-bye.
Have a good night, okay?